to sustain motivation you have to do two
things you probably already know first
you have to focus a lot of people have
that initial desire but they don't look
at their goals every single day they
don't revisit how did I do this week how
did I do in my health in my relationship
in my career how do I do with my
finances how did I do with any other
goals that I set up you have to have
that daily discipline to look and focus
on what you're doing and that weekly
review you also have to have the ability
to avoid distractions one of the reasons
people love my book the motivation
Manifesto is this teaches you how to set
boundaries how to say no how to push
away distraction to own your life again
but here's the deal when you're focusing
on something and you're really dialing
in it also brings your full presence
into something so you perform at higher
levels the second thing you need outside
of focus is sane motivation is everyday
effort it's the reason you have to set
up habits it's the reason you have to
have a daily routine a morning routine
it's the reason you have to make sure
you have a checklist of to-do's each day
I know that sounds so basic but here's
the funny thing a lot of people think
they'll have motivation one day then
they'll I'll put the effort out it's
like motivation first they think then
effort comes the motivation inspires the
effort right it's actually the opposite
in the science of motivation it's with
daily effort that motivation comes I
like to tell people this with momentum
comes more motivation don't wait for the
motivation to go out and take action
actually take action first because just
a little bit of progress a few quick
wins drops dopamine into the brain we
start feeling good and rewarded for our
behavior and suddenly we find ourselves
more motivation set three goals each day
knock off each of those three goals if
you just did that each and every single
day you'd start feeling more personal
power and you start getting ahead hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because in my first business I
quit in my business partner I was making
300 bucks a month and I didn't have the
motivation to keep going and the thing
that got me through was studying the
stories of entrepreneurs who've had
massive success and I hope that in
sharing these stories with you you find
a motivation to keep going and if I'm
being honest I still need the source for
myself today too so today let's learn
from one of the best Brandon burchard
and get some of his incredible
motivation
enjoy
social accountability
having other people around you who are
healthy
is as important as quote-unquote
biological luck
it's true the people around you really
do shape your expectations and how you
show up in the world and in this
category more than anything else if the
people around you tend to be healthy
whether that is emotionally healthy
mentally healthy physically healthy your
odds go way up especially the odds of
conscientious discipline and Design
your ability to
um surround yourself
with people who are in a good place
is one of the great gifts of our life we
are social animals a lot of what we do
in life is a memetic meaning we kind of
copy what we see of others we set
expectations on ourselves of what we see
of others a lot of our behaviors our
habits our mental models
are really a fact of sociology
and when you understand that the people
you surround yourself with you talk with
you look at you work out with you're
around you're healthier
I am a greatly healthier person in my
life because of my wife and for most men
out there or those who are Partners in
couples where one other partner is
healthier than the other that's one of
the greatest Gifts of all time you know
I'm a way healthier person I don't think
I knew what kale was until I met Denise
was kale what'd you talk about like I
hadn't I had no idea no idea broccoli
what what why wait that's probably how
come it's
dark like that I mean there are no
cheese on it I had no idea so that was
important for me to learn a lot about
and all of my friends in the health and
wellness category like being around them
all the time and seeing their posts and
their Instagrams or being at conferences
and studying their work or going to
conferences they're about health
surrounding myself in an ecosystem has
made me healthier
it really has if you look at where I
grew up
to where I am now I mean it's totally
different peer set
and that was by Design you might not get
to choose your biology or all your
family but you get to choose your peers
and your friends and The Inspirations
who you follow or learn from especially
in this category of Health once you have
that energetic Vision I promise you'll
surround yourself with better people
social accountability work out with
friends get a trainer they expect you to
show up so you show up Social
accountability surround yourself with
people who expect you to do well who
expect you to take care of yourself who
are empathetic when you're struggling
because they themselves are empathetic
people who struggle too right having
vulnerable
honest open
truthful transparent humans around us
who enable us and allow us to be
vulnerable
to share our hurts our pains our shames
our sadness increases our mental health
if the people around you tend to be
healthy whether that is emotionally
healthy mentally healthy physically
healthy your odds go way up especially
the odds of conscientious discipline and
Design
your ability to
um surround yourself
with people who are in a good place
is one of the great gifts of our life we
are social animals a lot of what we do
in life is a memetic meaning we kind of
copy what we see of others we set
expectations on ourselves of what we see
of others a lot of our behaviors our
habits our mental models
are really a fact of sociology
and when you understand that the people
you surround yourself with you talk with
you look at you work out with you're
around you're healthier
I am a greatly healthier person in my
life because of my wife and for most men
out there or those who are Partners in
couples where one other partner is
healthier than the other that's one of
the greatest Gifts of all time you know
I'm a way healthier person I don't think
I knew what kale was until I met Denise
was kale what'd you talk about like I
had I had no idea no idea broccoli what
what why wait that's probably how come
it's dark like that I mean there are no
cheese on it I had no idea so that was
important for me to learn a lot about
and all of my friends in the health and
wellness category like being around them
all the time and seeing their posts and
their Instagrams or being at conferences
and studying their work or going to
conferences they're about health
surrounding myself in an ecosystem has
made me healthier
it really has if you look at where I
grew up
to where I am now I mean it's totally
different peer set
and that was by Design you might not get
to choose your biology or all your
family but you get to choose your peers
and your friends and The Inspirations
who you follow or learn from especially
in this category of Health once you have
that energetic Vision I promise you'll
surround yourself with better people
when we don't have a vision
for next week next month next year life
can start to feel like we're just in you
know kind of in the swamp
and they were just going through the
motions and oh my God I'm working so
hard Brendan or oh my God but I have all
these reasons to be happy I I I already
have the great kids I I have a house I
can afford the car payments I mean I
have all these reasons to be happy but I
don't know something's missing I don't
feel purpose either
it's usually a disconnect or lack of
clarity
about your future
and I don't mean 10 years out or 50
years out I mean sometimes next month
and next year
really just uh sometimes it's just a
couple month Horizon and lacking Clarity
and connection with just the next couple
months or in some cases if you're a
longer term strategic kind of guy
the next year or two
I can feel that if I feel a disconnect
from my next year or two
I tend to lose a connection with purpose
a connection with motivation
uh I feel like the intentions or the
productivity of the day are kind of like
for what you know it's easy to go I'm
working so hard but for what
and that for what
I know equals vision
what is the vision of your next couple
months or next couple years
no one will give you that
it's time to sit down and think about
that it's why you all know I keep a
battle board over here on the wall and
my Battle Board is like it's basically
like a a
arts and crafts version of a yearly
schedule
it's like it's like a big piece of
butcher paper with 12 boxes drawn on it
and the 12 boxes each represents one
month of the year and I create themes
across the boxes I write the major
projects and deadlines up on the boxes
and I write a bunch of my values up
there and all I do is every day I just
kind of stare at it
I'm a person who is I'm really good any
person's here you're really good at just
living in the moment
I know a lot of people aren't good at
that but I'm really good
at just being here in the moment I've
had to teach myself to do that I'm not
as good
of making sure I'm connected to my
vision
or to a longer term plan
I I'm like
oh man I'm
into the future
the happiness goes down
I also see the luck tends to go down
when you're disconnected from a vision
so what do I do I force myself every day
when I come into this office
um I like in a home studio here when I
walk in I stare at that
for like and I force myself to stare at
it and think for five minutes I have a
little notepad next to me and I look at
where everything is lining up over the
next year sometimes the next two years
and I just look at it I mean if you
walked in I mean it's really not an
attractive thing I'm kind of like this
yeah
I'm just standing there kind of dumb
looking just looking at like and hoping
something comes into the brain that day
walking through each month even if I saw
it yesterday
I'm still going I'm just forcing myself
to look out
you know why people tend to be motivated
January 1st
because they're looking out again so
routine or we could call it a habit or
what I like to call in our high
performance research we talk about the
phrase of a deliberate
practice or a deliberate habit I
personally deeply believe that people
who want to be healthy who think their
habits are going to carry them over the
line don't know how work how life
actually works right we've fallen in
love with these simple gimmicky habits
that we're supposed to do and the way of
thinking about habits that's not how it
works when you grow
th requires deliberate habits not
automated habits just happen they're so
easy and also no deliver habits okay I'm
going to do this today I'm going to
implement this thing I'm going to choose
to do that as a routine as a practice as
a deliberate habit that I have to like
conscientiously decide to go to even
it's hard
routines
you know those might be
eating well
working out well
sleeping well
finding out what works for you which
we'll talk about in a moment
but here's the deal if you don't know
your routines if you don't have patterns
practices or plans for your health
how are you supposed to ever feel your
best or even feel better
you gotta have a plan in place
one of my favorite things to do
is when I work with a client and some of
you know when I work with like
one-on-one with a client it's a big deal
I rarely do that anymore you're talking
about like seven figure levels of work
very rare that I'll do that with but one
of my favorite things to do with an
actual paying client is ask them to take
a picture for me
of their list
of health habits
and you know what they usually say
oh gosh brand I don't have one
I go nowhere written down in your house
is a list
of your health habits or your health
goals it's not written down well no
did you ever Journal about it
well yeah I guess one time you know on
New Year's four years ago
they don't even it's not even written
there's no plan
they'll tell you I'll ask what you're
well you know I I like this routine or
you know I like kale you know they'll
tell you something you know I had to
drop a kale joke up in here it'll be
like they'll have an idea
they'll have a list of things that
they'll pontificate on that works for
them once in a while
it's nowhere written down
you know I love my friends when for the
first time they go to run a marathon and
often they'll get a coach or they'll
start reading books on it or uh you know
they'll look something up on the
internet and realize oh to run a
marathon there's a plan
and listen if you just go in and try to
run a marathon yourself I guess a small
percentage of the planet could figure it
out and actually pull it off the rest of
us humans we follow a plan that plan is
starting small getting a little bit
better focusing on these things running
a little bit longer and a little bit
longer and a little bit better and all
of a sudden you ran a marathon it's an
incremental approach but guess what
there's a plan
no plan no gains
no plan no change
no goals no growth
and so if you want Health to be
something important in your life where's
the list where's the plan even it's
simple
we need the routine we need the plan we
need the goals write it down do it today
put it in your journal in growth day go
make a plan in growth there I'm going to
start doing these things put it in there
set reminders and growth day literally
you can pop up you can write your
reminders and growth Day drink water
have it pop up a couple times a day as a
notification you know eat healthy
tonight have it pop up as a reminder you
can set up reminders and growth day if
you didn't know which are a hugely
popular thing for People's Health so go
set up reminders just go to the plan
section of your growth Day app after
this broadcast today and set up your
plan you have to find what feels good
for you what feels good for me as an
example a calm
slow morning
I'm I'm pretty dumb in the morning I'm
slow to Rouse in the morning I like to
you know kind of Shuffle around the
house you know get a tea or coffee and
it'll sit down with the with my book
a little piece of paper or my journal
and just like a slow morning
a slow morning is great for my mental
health that's for me right my wife is
the opposite she's incredible by like by
like 10 a.m she has done more than most
humans in a decade I don't know how she
does it shout out to Denise like dude
like one of the most amazing
like she can she wakes up and a list of
things download into her brain
and she just starts going at him it's
unbelievable we'll talk about a morning
person I I me my mom the opposite my dad
he well he could he was ready up and go
to work because he was in the military
all his life biologically we all have
different rhythms don't we right some of
those are conditioned and we create some
of that's how we are I think I
conditioned my slow morning because I
like it
what feels good to me is a slow morning
how simple is that how controllable is
that even if there's chaos and there's a
lot going on I can find my moments which
we'll talk about I can find my moments
to recalibrate and reset even if it's
hectic and crazy because there's people
around the house or something's going on
still I got to make sure that that
morning finds those moments of calm and
peace and intention for myself otherwise
it can really frazzle out a lot of the
day if you wrote down your three top
priorities for the day do those first
before you do your social media before
you reply to everyone's DMs
inbox uh you know voice message text
it's like listen I have so many people
who
they spend all day just checking their
email to reply to everybody else now
that's fine if that's your job if that's
customer service do that that's your job
but if you're an entrepreneur as an
example or you have a whole list of
other priorities and you're just
checking into other people's agendas all
day to meet all their obligations and
you keep missing your key priorities day
after day after day after day your brain
doesn't feel like you're capable anymore
even though you might be smart you're
competent but your brain doesn't believe
you're capable you've got to develop the
pattern of taking the action the pattern
of taking the action better yet the
pattern of taking the action to complete
the key priorities
so all I want you to do as a daily
simple habit every morning we do it in
the high performance planner I write
down my key priorities for the day do
those first
get those out of the way make that
happen maybe that's your morning maybe
for me
I didn't feel capable of my career for a
long time because I'm replying to
everybody and I did a simple thing I
said you know what no phone calls till 1
pm in the afternoon my time
that leaves the morning to do the most
important work
because I do the most important work
almost every morning of my life
I feel incredibly capable give me a task
list give me that log is happening in
the brain good job today good job today
good job today good job that consistency
that congruence developed the capability
now I feel capable and I am capable
because I executed
because I executed so many times I
develop the scale you all follow this is
so important if you don't have
self-acceptance clearly you don't have
authentic self-confidence
if you don't have self acceptance
clearly you won't have an authentic
sense of happiness because you don't
even like yourself
so what do we do about this when I'm
coaching others
well first after I've tried to
understand where that's coming from that
solution driven part of coaching is
about realizing there's things we all do
to gain greater self-acceptance your
self
wants to realize itself
right we all want to reach a fuller
higher standard of our potential right
we we all want that we I've never met a
person in my life who didn't want to
realize a higher level of potential for
themselves or their family or their
teams or their work and I know some
people like no no you don't know my kid
he's 42 and he's still on the couch I
don't have a judgment for that what I
have to say about that is this
that person does too
it's built in the human spirit
we all want to grow
we all want to be happy
sometimes we get discouraged from that
enough
that we lie to ourselves and say we
don't want it or worse
we don't deserve it
many people don't have self-acceptance
because they don't believe they deserve
it
they think that they did something wrong
they had other people judge them
they had that experience when they've
had so much negativity around them they
started to believe that story
and so what I share with you about
self-acceptance
um it's one of the reasons I'm a very
big proponent of coaching or of therapy
a lot of self-acceptance is actually
socially gained
you know there's a reason that the
psychology department tends to be in the
same building as a sociology Department
because they go hand in hand we are
social animals a lot of your acceptance
of yourself actually has nothing to do
with self-acceptance your acceptance
yourself came from how people treated
you before it was socially gained and
constrained
you started to believe that you were at
a certain level based on how other
people around you treated you isn't true
in one way
to gain greater self-acceptance is to
take back that self part and say oh I'm
going to do the work on me right now
I'm going to take some time to work on
myself again and I am going to lessen
the noise of the negative people around
me and get around positive people who
amplify the noise of positivity
it doesn't mean get around yes persons
it means get around yes spirited persons
people who are supportive and
encouraging of you you probably have one
positive friend talk to them more often
hang out with them more often lean on
them more
I think that's critical
because the easiest way to develop off
in the self is in our social environment
getting other more positive healthy
people around us tends to lift all boats
the other thing to think about with the
acceptance part
is to learn
to be in the moment in such a way that
you can forgive the things you did in
the past you are feel potential you want
to feel a purpose it
of service
acts of compassion kindness generosity
with the people around you
are you providing great service
as a husband a wife a role model a team
leader
Service as in servant leadership
Service as in generosity
Service as in doing a good job with
heart and soul
that's what we mean by service
my short answer is
I hope that a lot of what you do in life
feels like you're doing it from a
generous Soulful place
a generous Soulful place if you're a mom
and you are generous and Soulful with
your kids good job if you're a leader of
a big company and a mom and you're doing
it from a generous and A Soulful Place
good job
if you're a volunteer and you do it from
a generous and Soulful Place good job
if you're trying to lead a team and
you've had the guts to ask how do I do
this well you've probably read about
servant leadership and Robert
greenleaf's work in servant leadership
you go oh okay the servant kind of leads
from the back
the servant is the guide by the side not
the person pushing with the stick
the servant
has heart and soul because they have
compassion and empathy for others
and boy do I think we need to develop
this because we've gone from a service
mindset
and one part of last century to a selfie
narcissistic culture
that has forgot others
and literally passes people struggling
by on the road like their pieces of
trash that's where we that's where we're
at as a society
and it's going to be the volunteers and
the leaders and the servant leaders who
are going to change this world and I
hope that's you and I give you a round
of pause if you are that person who's
generous and showing up for people and
giving your best to your kids and to
your team and your fellow members very
few people do that and that you do that
I honor you and I thank you for that
it's much much needed it's more needed
now
than any time I've ever seen
this moment that we're experiencing in
life the reason a lot of people are
feeling so lacking in purpose is because
there's so much negativity in the
environment there's so much narcissism
in the environment
we're you know completely bombarded and
scrolling by all these acts of selfie
culture and narcissism and so few
demonstrations of beauty
of humanity
of genuine moments where someone takes a
beat out of their day to help somebody
or to be with somebody
and when you're willing to do that
part of purpose
is sensing
a mission larger than yourself I don't
think there's a more easy access to a
greater sense of purposeful being than
being more intentional
in the relationships we have
but that often happens because
one of two things
either one we suddenly realize that the
purpose of life is manifested through
our relationships
the purpose of life is manifested
through our relationships you've heard
all the growth day teachers talk about
the research about how it's your
relationships that actually leads to the
highest levels of not only positive
well-being not only life satisfaction
but longevity
the biggest study of the longest living
people on the planet happens to be
completely showing that the the highest
correlation to life length and positive
life like meaning you lived a good life
and you lived a long life
came from people who had one or two deep
meaningful relationships and they found
purpose in that they found purpose in
their children or they found Purpose
with their wife or their spouse or their
partner or their family
there was purpose there and sometimes
purpose in the social realm can really
fill us up in the South Realm so for
those of you who are struggling with
yourself know that maybe deepen some of
those relationships around you reminder
to all of you
if you're struggling in any
relationships in your life
that is as a growth day Pro member when
you click the learn section
and you watch past events under the Live
Events section
you'll be able to see an entire month's
training
that you can sort by on relationships
and I think that's a really important
call out here we've got and it like I I
taught relationships for two hours there
Jenna Kutcher did Koya Webb did Anthony
trucks did all of all eight of our
teachers or so taught an hour on how
they
have learned about relationships from
research or their coaching or teaching
practice and what they do in their own
life to develop those relationships you
know what feels good for me planning
planning if you look at my my growth day
my plan it's full it's filled out with
plans and deadlines and reminders if you
look at next to my computer there's all
these checklists written down like I and
by the way I don't naturally do that I
actually don't like planning I love the
mental and emotional effect of planning
anyone follow that one
yeah you guys see right that's the
Difference Maker for me I don't like the
act of sitting down and doing it's not
like I find tons of joy in organizing my
life I just don't
I love the mental Clarity the peace the
progress that comes from making plans
write down your goals write down your
deadlines identify your projects know
who you need to reach out to know who
you're waiting on know what your
priorities are of the day if you need
any advice on this in growth day
remember you can go to the learn section
you can smash the Watch past events and
you can watch an entire month of
training on productivity you can go to
your courses and watch an entire
training on the habit of productivity
from the world's number one you know I'm
sorry the world's you know largest
research study on high performance
habits that high performance habit
Builder course that you have unlocked in
the course section
of your app just go to the learn section
go to courses and you can see high
performance habit Builder there's a
whole section just on productivity
and that productivity isn't done just to
get ahead and just succeed it's because
you feel better when you organize your
life better
when you lead life and live life with
more intention
when you have a little bit more clarity
you feel better
strip away someone's clarity
their intention their connection with
what they need to do today and misery
sets in over time we just know it
with no connection to Our intention and
our future we feel less motivated and
good today
that's why the plan is so important for
me would you go to
you know one of your random neighbor's
house
would you go there
and you know pull up in a big with a big
dump truck of garbage and shovels and
and just go start shoveling in and
breaking their windows and vandalizing
their house
of course everyone says well no I
wouldn't unless you hate your neighbor
what are you talking about Brandon when
I vandalize my neighbor's house and
throw garbage in of course I wouldn't
and yet we vandalized the very Temple
that we have been given
we throw garbage in the very Temple that
we have been given
and what I found through years of
studying psychology but also actually
doing the academic research and also
doing the field testing with all our
millions of high performance clients
over the years is as one self-respect
and self-worth go up
their health habits improve
in fact often when their health habits
improve their self-respect goes up I
really believe it is a Perpetual
Evergreen Loop someone with greater
self-respect and self-love of course
they want to care for their Temple
because they care for their life
they kill they care for their energetic
Force they see themselves as stewards of
the temple or stewards of the energy or
the spark inside
they care for their energy levels
because they care for themselves
and I've been there so if you think I'm
preaching here for those who don't know
my story and when I was 19 years old I
had suicidal ideation and planning
I'd had a huge breakup in my life
I did not have the emotional tools
needed to deal with that situation in my
life
and so I fell into a deep pattern of
self-hatred
and stop taking care of myself
entirely I mean entirely not eating not
showering not you know doing anything
and so I understand that path I've been
down that path I've coached through that
path and I have to share with you that
we have to be attentive
to the Deep correlation
between how we care about ourselves and
think of ourselves and our self-worth
and our health practices
it's really vital it's very important if
you're not taking care of yourself
there's an emotional reason and an
identity reason something about yourself
that you are blocked by upset about
angry about sometimes disgusted about or
there's that self-hatred and so I'm
telling here I'm telling you I'm here to
tell you that is one reason especially
in the world of mental health I'm always
like see a therapist if your health
practices have sucked for two decades
if you're a health practice has sucked
for a decade
don't blame it on your sweet tooth
go see a therapist
get some emotional support to understand
what's the underlying thing happening
here that I'm not taking care of myself
so I begin our health conversation by
recommending therapy if you have not
been practicing health habits well
especially over a period of time there's
sometimes trauma there
are sometimes negative self-talk there
there's sometimes patterns that are hard
to break without a professional
assisting you and so I'm always that
person who's like hey I'm going to tell
you to optimize I'm going to challenge
you I'm also going to say if you really
struggled with this for a long time get
some help babe sometimes you need that
and so please hear that respectfully
from me because I care about your health
there is a evolutionary and a biological
reason that you feel the way that you do
right there is it's very important to
understand in both I really believe
mental health and physical health it is
that kind of 50 50 kind of thing
and when we blend it together by the way
but there's no question that some people
biologically feel more fatigued or more
depressed or more anxious we have to
understand that you and me are not the
same
biologically in how our energy might be
and I hope that that always introduces
empathy and compassion
that there's a big luck card that we get
I have friends literally who are born
without limbs
I have friends who are born with
conditions in which their brain
functions in very unhealthy ways I have
friends who've died so early of cancer
I have friends who um have struggled
with mental health
I have friends who've committed suicide
I have friends and family who struggle
constantly with all sorts of biological
health issues that is quote unquote not
their fault and it's important to
realize that
some of you
you feel terrible biologically even
though you're drinking all your water
you're eating all your greens you do
move and you do exercise
and so I'm here to say there is no
preaching we all have to take the cards
we've been dealt and figure out how to
care for ourselves
how to optimize the best that we can how
to improve
even if it's a little bit incremental by
incremental but it starts with a
biological understanding of where you're
at and this is why again as a person
who's not a medical professional I'm
like listen if you don't understand
closely how you feel and why you feel
the way that you do
please please please if you've never
done it go get a full workup of every
friggin Health test you can as an adult
as somebody who's accountable for your
health go get the blood test go see the
nutritionists or the dietitians go work
out with the trainer go literally do all
the genetic testing that you can do to
understand what's up with you
I always tell the story of A friend of
mine who's one of my partners in one of
my businesses one of my best friends in
the world who discovered at the age of
40.
that you know every morning he always
had the sniffles and his nose was
running and he's clearing his throat and
everything and found at the age of 40.
that he was allergic to eggs
at the age of 40. didn't know spent 40
years having these reactions that made
him fatigued and blowing his nose and
everything because he was allergic to
eggs
and I think that's a sad thing about our
society is that we're not
taught or trained or honestly empowered
or equipped or served
with some simple Health
um support When We're Young that says
hey look seems like you're allergic to
this thing don't eat it I mean how is
that not part of our educational process
right or or or or or or or or or our
Health Care system that of course we
would all find out very early on and be
tested multiple stages of our life
including every new decade
what are we allergic to
what preconditions might we have
what's our genetic what's our genetic
makeup leading us towards so this is
where I say health is luck right Health
might be luck but it's your job to be
aware
your job no one else says no one's going
to come and save you here you've got to
do the testing and see the medical
professionals professionals and
dietitians and people who can help you
optimize and care for your body I
believe that has to be something we
demand of ourselves it's not served to
us at least not in society I live in so
we have to take accountability for that
so health is luck dot dot dot just
challenge yourself
just challenge yourself
challenge yourself at the gym next time
challenge yourself when you're on the
road next time to go a little bit
further challenge yourself to get a
little faster challenge yourself to be a
little more mobile or flexible challenge
yourself to stay a little longer in that
yoga pose challenge yourself to reset
your mindset after you get angry or hurt
or down if you're not challenging
yourself who is I know people say but
Brendan isn't perfectionism such a
problematic thing in mental health I'm
like totally totally that is a super
thin slice the reality is perfectionism
isn't the problem the problem is people
think they should be perfect but
perfecting ourselves growing into our
full potential expecting a lot of
ourselves that can be done in healthy
ways especially when you consider all
the things we've talked about today
it's okay to challenge yourself again
last time you might have challenged
yourself maybe you got down on yourself
this time as you challenge yourself
allow the grace do it with social
accountability have an energetic Vision
recalibrate find what feels good for you
and stick to that
you can figure out a way to feel better
you can figure out a way to get
healthier it's going to be on your own
path in your own way no one can tell you
all the right ways to do that you'll
probably need support you'll probably
take months and months and months and
years and years and years to figure it
out and often you'll fall off the wagon
you'll do a terrible thing you'll make a
bad choice but you'll recalibrate and
you'll keep getting better because you
and I both know that every day is a
great day to grow I want to thank you
all for this incredible session today on
health I hope you enjoyed I hope you'll
share with family and friends if it
supported you just go tell people what
we're doing here at growth day like holy
they're having an entire month of
conversations about health about mental
health emotional physical health right
here in growth they will be live every
single week with you guys as always on
our Wednesday wisdoms so tune back in
watch the replays make a commitment
Journal today about your energy Vision
please do that please stay
please stay on path please take care of
yourself please be kind to yourself
please practice self-respect and
self-love you deserve a vibrant and
energetic life do your work to move
towards that to align with that to honor
that impulse and know that you don't
have to do it alone we're all doing it
together we're all figuring out together
we're all on this journey together
that's why we always say every day is a
great day to grow together you're gonna
fall off the wagon you're gonna have a
suck day you're going to be unmotivated
you're going to eat that pizza you're
going to do something that you know you
shouldn't do
because your current mood or the choice
of passion or Joy or spontaneity or the
thing that you like is there
and the most important thing in health
isn't just knowing what to do or having
that plan it's recalibrating when you
fall off
you know in the mental health space and
the personal coaching space we both use
the same term for this it's called
resilience
it's okay
challenge problem something didn't go
the way I'd planned
can I find my strength again find my
focus again and keep progressing
today we're just going to call that
Health recalibrations recalibrations
okay so what you didn't work out
yesterday and you planned two do it
today
okay you ate the terrible food make the
better choice for the next four meals
it's what people do is instead they made
a bad choice they did something bad
self-hatred increased
and so they stop
they stop trying
you know you're down on yourself when
you stop trying you know you're down on
yourself when you don't recalibrate
after a fail
you know you're down on yourself when
something doesn't go right you fail you
feel bad about yourself and you stop
the idea that we talk about here in
growth day all the time it's just making
self-improvement a way of life tomorrow
improve get better try again okay you
you had a huge Outburst guess what I
have a huge Outburst do I keep
outbursting for hours and hours and
hours no huge outbursts whoa that was
off let me go recalibrate over here let
me go on a walk let me bounce in place
take 10 deep breaths let me lay on the
floor do a release meditation let me
stand back up write out my intentions
and go
I don't get down on myself or angry
about myself what I do is go well that's
not what I wanted that wasn't my
intention that wasn't good
okay recalibrate so I reset my body I
reset my mind I reset my intentions and
I go you got it that's recalibrating
you don't stop and beat yourself up you
go okay let me recalibrate reset
right that is so important the reset or
what I'm calling a recalibration is
everything
and here's what happens
the longer between incident and
recalibration
the worse your health
right people say well
I missed three weeks of working out
screw it guess it doesn't matter
no recalibration so now those three
weeks turn into Six turn into nine turn
to years
but if instead of getting down to
yourself or stopping you said
okay I missed it for three weeks in a
row let me reset what do I really want
here how can I do better let me try
again it's just keep going I know that's
so simplistic but we have to keep
progressing
if we stop
not only do we stop the forward momentum
we increase
I should say we decrease our self-esteem
our self-respect goes down
because we know we should be doing
something for ourselves but we don't
and so this is really important to
understand and hear recalibrate recalib
and make it fast like resiliency doesn't
take five years you know what
recalibrations can happen in moments you
maybe had a bad morning but you're here
you're working on yourself you're here
on growth Day saying you know what I
just sometimes the the the instruction
the positivity the perspective even or
just the reminders it's helpful
every time I listen to a growth day
teacher I feel better not because
everything changed in an instant because
it just it resets me to right okay good
mindset good habits I can do that here I
go
so it's just a recalibration it's a
recalibration I can't tell you how many
bad days I have or bad hours I should
say emotionally that I have that I
choose by the end of the day to
recalibrate okay I had a terrible
morning
whoo let me go for a walk
let me get a bunch of water let me get
some food in my stomach so I'm not
hangry let me come back do a 10 minute
release meditation some seven or eight
Vinyasa flows on the floor get back up
look at my goals on the wall write out
my intentions make my action plan and
get two things done
end of day I feel better
you follow I'm not perfect
and neither are you
but we are perfecting ourselves
we are in motion of progress when we
recalibrate more quickly so have it in
mind okay bad morning recalibrate bad
hour recalibrate bad conflict
recalibrate for Miss the workout
recalibrate eat the bad thing
recalibrate I hope that serves you have
you ever had the pain point where you
perceive yourself different than
everybody else around you you know you
think you're this great amazing person
and other people around you are being
mean or maybe sometimes you're like down
on yourself but everyone's like no
you're awesome I love you what's wrong I
love you if you ever had that it's like
there's this challenge sometimes between
our self-perception and how other people
perceive us so the first thing you have
to do is make sure every single day that
you have a very clear intention for who
you want to be I know you've been
watching my YouTube hopefully for a long
time and you hear me talk about this it
you can't keep bumbling into each day
and just reacting all day you have to
have an intention for like what kind of
person do I want to show up to the world
as like how do I want to be perceived
and be real really clear about that
don't just like wander into social
situations all throughout High School
all throughout College all throughout
your professional life showing up as you
do normally instead go how do I really
be in the situation how do I want to
feel in the situation how do I want to
treat people in this situation how do I
want other people to perceive me not in
a some kind of method of Conformity but
rather like what's the real me
if you can't articulate the real you
please don't ask other people to figure
it out
if you're not clear about your own
values how you want the world to see you
and what you want to accomplish please
don't ask the world to know who you are
and what you're about
so it begins with that intention that
Clarity of self first you got to do the
homework you got to do the personal
development you got to read the books
you got to geek out and figure out your
values your drives how you want to show
up to people what your goals are because
if you don't know it I promise you we're
never going to figure it out and I think
a lot of people are really miserable in
their life because they're like no one
understands me but they don't understand
themselves or they don't understand
themselves and communicate who they are
so it all begins with intention all
begins with Clarity you gotta start by
defining yourself and every day look at
it I mean like literally every day like
what are the words that should Define
how you're going to be today I have
people write that down every single day
like I want to be a person who is and
write it out I want to treat other
people like this because if every day
you show up as that person and you treat
people like this then Integrity starts
happening in your life you have that
congruence of being who you really want
to be and more people see you on a
consistent basis being like you versus
scatter shock just reacting or
conforming or trying to fit in now when
you know you and you show up as you more
often they go I get you so the second
big thing you can do is learn by
discussion this is the hardest thing to
do and what this means is ask other
people how they perceive you I mean it's
the hardest thing but let's say you got
a job and you have a great meeting and
you feel good about the meeting lots of
people walk out and just go celebrate
and they'll go so I guess I did a great
job instead ask other people like how
did that meeting go for you how do you
think I did was there anything else I
could do better how do you think of the
way I talk to this person is there
anything that you feel like I missed
and just start asking other people to
share their perceptions of you and your
performance it is the gutsiest scariest
thing in the world for people to do
because most people don't want feedback
but if you never solicit feedback if
you're not consistent and asking for it
then people just don't say it and then
one day they're like well I think you're
like this and you're like how could you
say that we've been in a relationship
for 10 years and they're like I guess
you never asked
so you gotta ask ask consistently and
constantly and almost everything you do
be like how is that did I come across as
this I was trying to go for that did it
work I mean even as we're shooting this
video you know today I shot a couple of
these and I asked my team I'm like do
you think that was like too slow was it
too fast did I get my points across
because if you don't ask that you don't
know and a lot of the external feedback
that comes from others can give you the
real direction for how to be better I
know it's scary I know it's like well
people might say negative things but if
you realize all you're trying to do is
learn not judge everything goes fine if
all you're trying to do is say hey just
give me the honest feedback and don't
worry about saying it exactly right I
won't get hooked I won't get mad you got
to actually have those conversations
with people allow them to share the
feedback and don't take it personally
take it as a learning point that either
applies and is true for you or not like
I get a lot of feedback I'm like I don't
agree with that that's not true I I
don't think that's true for me I'll try
to do better next time to make sure that
that doesn't happen but I don't ever
hold it against other people now is it
true that some people are going to be
mean to you is it true some people are
going to call you names is it true some
people are going to be hard on you yeah
that's that's part of life so don't be
surprised by it anymore you're too old
now to be surprised by other people
being a jerk to you you should know that
it's going to happen you should know
people are going to give you negative
feedback and what you have to do is
start learning to take feedback from
people who know how to deliver it if
someone gives terrible feedback and
they're a terrible jerk and they're
always that way man don't take that
personally just know that's their style
that's their thing that's their life
that's their you know acts to grind not
yours we're always trying to improve our
lives but life is hard things mess you
up people judge you finances are hard
and you're always trying to be your best
but sometimes that ain't easy and so I
think developing habits of Mind Body
Spirit productivity service love
can really change your life and I'll
start this morning with a super funny
story uh about just a life-changing
habit of mine you can see I'm in a new
space uh this morning I'm literally in a
shared office right now
and
if I I'll give you a play-by-play of
like the last
41 minutes
41 minutes ago
the power in my studio went out
I'm typing an email to I think about 41
minutes yeah about yeah 41 minutes if
I'm doing the right math right uh and I
figure out about that time that oh wait
no the it's the power to the whole house
and my studio my studio is in like Our
Guest House
and you know I've got the broadcast
camera you guys have all seen over the
years and you know it looks nice setup
and everything
I'm typing an email to all the create
accounts in
um growth day about another promotion
and and also everything goes out
now I know I got this live with you guys
at the top of the hour and I was like
okay
didn't expect that
take a few deep breaths out
swear five times stand up and I go
outside looking for what's happening and
like is there someone out there they've
turned off the power what's going on
across the street what's because there's
construction and I'm looking around
what's happening can't figure it out go
into the house and like I said that
whole house
power seems out
go to uh ask Denise my wife
hey do you know what I think of it is
someone doing anything with the house
there's no power I'm live in like an
hour
she's like no I I I don't know and she'd
just been getting out of the shower
she's like I don't know so I go blazing
outside
uh go look across the street there's
construction going on I pick up the
phone call the project manager over
there and I go did you guys just shut
off the power is something going on and
we're doing this Landscaping project so
I bolt over there asked you guys did you
guys are you digging are you digging
anything have you hit power no
and run back into the house
uh and Denise is like hey I just got a
notice from PG e
powers out but doesn't say anything
about just says notice we you know it's
kind of as Texas says hey your power
might be out like yeah we figured it out
so I go okay
uh I think okay well
um what am I gonna do
I'm live at the top of the hour so I
said okay well and probably come back on
you know probably yeah who's had that
Zoom moment where your power went out
and you just thought it'll come back on
anyone else is just like just Faith
you're thinking about it okay power's
gonna come back on
I said okay but what if it doesn't
so I start packing up a spare laptop
because my other laptop is connected to
all the gear right just in case it comes
on I've got that fancy camera and
everything
oh hold out and I run back inside I said
Okay
um
I'm gonna drive into town and get that
shared office space that we know about
hit up my assistant say can can you book
a space for me I'm gonna I'm gonna be
going in
and then the project manager from across
the street says hey it's not us God
knows from PG e and he sends me this
audio it says there will be no power
till one o'clock
which I'm on Pacific time so that's two
and a half that's three hours away but I
gotta be live with you at the top of the
hour
so okay I listen to the thing the audio
says no no power till one o'clock
the next text comes in from the project
manager hey
I'm coming I'm trying to come over uh to
see if it's anything about your property
because he also worked on our property I
can't get in the gate
we have a gate at the beginning of a
property that's powered
and so all of a sudden I realized
I can't get in my car and drive down to
the shared space because I can't get my
car out of our property the gate don't
open
I'm like oh my God
and this is where that first habit comes
in
I take a deep breath anytime there's a
huge Interruption when you meet a master
negotiator
a master coach a master therapist a
master you know role model who really
understands how to do communication well
in Conflict what they're doing is
they're reflecting
restating and rephrasing
things that the other person are
bringing to them
they're reflecting rephrasing or
restating what other people said
in order to demonstrate understanding
someone says I'm so pissed at you
it's as easy saying I hear that you're
pissed
if someone says I'm so hurt that you did
that
it's saying
I know that you're hurt
if someone says you know
um
I I
I'm I'm so angry
I hear that you're angry
it's just reflecting back the feelings
they they are stating to you
and I mean literally use the explicit
one even if you don't agree with it
right if they say you're being
condescending
to me
I hear that you feel I'm being
condescending
right it's as simple as just reflecting
the words right back you don't have to
validate you don't even have to agree
it's just hearing it it's restating it
back to them it's reflecting it it says
I'm listening to you I heard the words
that you chose to use
right and it's reflecting back the
feelings if they don't a lot of people
don't know how to access feelings you
know research shows most people only
have access to like three to four words
to describe their feelings happy mad sad
and Confused
happy mad sad and Confused that's most
people don't know how to say any other
words in that they have no emotional
training right I never did I had like
happy and mad that's all I grew up with
I was like happy mad that was that was
that was it there was no Nuance of all
the other feelings that we could have
so most people
they might not know how to communicate
it and so if you're sensing it one way
to reflect it is
I'm
I'm sensing that you're upset is that
right
and it's saying I sense it and asking to
help you gauge the feeling
or it's just saying I say to coaching
clients all the time especially now in
this virtual world I say it on zoom and
as many of you guys know my coaching
clients paid a million dollars a year to
work with me so I'll look at them right
on zoom and say you know what um can we
take a Beat
I'm listening but I can't quite gauge
here through this virtual world what is
it what it is you're feeling
could you describe that to me
I know that sounds so you know junior
varsity but I literally say that
to CEOs I say that to Olympians I say
that to my friends my partners my spouse
I say it all the time hey can we can we
take a beat here
I'm not sure I'm picking up what is it
is your feeling can you can you describe
what you're feeling right now I can't
tell
I say that all the time and now it just
opened up the platform for them to
express feelings
and that's really important for a lot of
people especially if you're dealing with
somebody who doesn't say what they feel
or it's hard to read it on their face
to say hey can we take a beat a minute I
can't tell what you're feeling right now
that really can open up the door to
better conversation I am a person who
builds positive relationships
imagine you've got to go have that
difficult conversation at work with that
underperforming employee there they are
in the glass conference room Cube and
you know you have to go in there and
deliver some truthful feedback that
they're underperforming
if your mindset is this person sucks I
hate them how are you going to treat
them if your intention is I need to get
this person to change or I'm going to
fire them
how are you going to treat them
but if the intention is
I'm a person who builds positive
relationships okay stepping into this
conversation from that truth
I want to be a role model
I want to build positive lasting
conversations and relationships with
other people
okay let me start with that
it is entering a con conversation with
the intention to build the relationship
let me say that again it's entering the
conversation with the clear intention to
build the relationship
at home that sounds like honey I love
you I'm always trying to figure out ways
that we can make the relationship better
I have some ideas and
um I'd love if we could have a
conversation
at work it's as simple as you know what
your relationships with your co-workers
here really matter and we're trying to
build something really special together
and I know you're part of that so we
need to have a conversation
it's just baselining everybody and
reminding everybody
that we're here to build a relationship
see when you're angry
what is your usual intention
I'm here to end this relationship F this
person they're out
and now from that frame from that
intention how do you treat people
my intention is to fire this
underperforming jerk
okay you're gonna have a very different
conversation
intentioned is the very thing that will
change you for the rest of your life I
know many of you heard me talk about my
experiences with Oprah Winfrey and uh
the blessing of doing some courses with
her and her network and um really
learning a lot from her and one thing I
just I was always amazed by when she
starts any meeting she always asks
what's Our intention for this meeting
your environment shapes you because
you're soaking it
and so make sure the relationships you
have are high quality now this is
everyone's but Brandon you understand my
spouse well he's a doozy you know it's
like listen if you're around people
who aren't like this the job isn't to
get rid of them and throw them away
the job is to go build that group
somewhere else
to find that
to find that to build it if you didn't
get it
right and you didn't just luckily fall
into a group I didn't have that I grew
up in a town that had been economically
depressed for a century
I grew up in a town that there it was so
survival mindset but also very
aggressive and competitive there there
wasn't a whole lot of talk about these
things and I had to go find and build it
I had to start going to personal
development seminars I had to engage
with higher Achievers I had to look for
people who had fulfillment in their
lives no matter what they were doing and
I had to seek them out and I made that a
choice I made that a decision I said I'm
going to create an awesome group of
people be around my life I don't know
how but I'm going to do networking I'm
gonna do volunteering I'm gonna ask to
be around people and I'm going to get
mentors and I'm I'm going to make sure
that I surround myself with people who
care about life
who want to live meaningful and
fulfilling Lives who want to lead who
want to make a difference and I can't
think a single person at all in my
entire life today you know after that
was that decision was 25 years ago for
me
I can't think of a single person who I
have a consistent or recurring
communication with in my entire life
who isn't like that now
every person to a person
to a t every person I interact with has
some sense of that or they don't get in
my world it doesn't mean I'm unfair or
discount people it just means I'm not
going to let that stuff into my head
and I don't say that I'm perfect I say
it took me 20 years like I said that's
gonna be a goal I'm gonna get there and
I want you to have that goal like the
people around you should be so fulfilled
and so happy and grateful for their
lives
and you gotta find that
you got to lead that you got to
cultivate that you got to talk about
that I think fulfillment should be a
topic that people talk about every
single month of their life
if you're in relationship with someone
ask your spouse your partner hey
do you feel fulfilled
and just hold that space
if they don't feel fulfilled
ask why
get to know them understand what they're
really looking for encourage them to go
in the direction that will bring them
that fulfillment
encourage them you know at the end of a
bad day when you hear them say send
separate sentence of negative self-talk
or meaning after meaning
that's catastrophic
terrible negative awful
be that encourager
be that person who helps them maybe
think about or become more aware of that
self-talk or those labels or that
meaning you can do it without judgment
but you can also be committed to
building the circle of influence that
you deserve in your life at this stage
of your life you have to be
conscientious about it you got to get at
it because when those people around you
are living a life of impact and meaning
and fulfillment it lifts you up I have
down days and then I talk to somebody in
my circle and it's like whoa it just
kind of resets my brain a little bit
and I go oh I've been speaking negative
oh I've been thinking small or I would
and all right okay yeah I am lucky I'm
blessed oh my gosh let's go Brandon can
I get back on because sometimes you will
drown in your own discouragement and it
is your circle of influence the people
around you people in your network who
can help draw you out of that faster and
that is something to be grateful for
practice emotional regulation
practice emotional regulation
and we're going to talk about what that
means because here's what happens
you have two choices in a conflict
situation you have emotional regulation
or you have emotional Contagion
you'd better make that choice
consciously
emotional regulation or emotional
Contagion
so what is emotional contagion emotional
contagion is that part of us that we are
hardwired
to do which is mimic
or act out respond to
someone else's emotions
it's how when you walk up to a group of
three people who are sad you start to
feel sad it's how a an eight-month year
old baby Mel Abraham will will when you
smile at the eight month year old and
you and they they smile back they can't
help it
what's happening there
that's in your brain and your prefrontal
cortex these things called your mirror
neurons
that make you or in your cortex it helps
you
want to mimic other people and match
their emotions
it's why when someone yawns you yawn
it's why when someone gets super angry
you feel your blood go up
it's automatic it's impulsive and it is
hard wired
until we run a new program over so many
times
that that gets stampined maybe it
doesn't go away but it gets dampened
right
emotional regulation however is a
conscious choice
to sense and feel the emotions coming up
and to regulate them appropriately
for my intentions or the situation
it means you take the reins of your
emotions and your feelings and your
behaviors it means you're personally
responsible for it and that's hard
because if you heard me teach on this
before there's a big difference between
emotions and feelings I talked about it
in a daily fire
that your emotions psychologically so
when we talk about emotions in in my
field of practice whether it is in what
actually doesn't matter what field of
practice if it's in Psychology if it's
in coaching work emotions are automatic
physical
impulsive
and very difficult
to dictate
their extremity
very it's just like emotions tend to
happen
feelings however
think about feelings are kind of like
the wake of an emotion
but you get to apply meaning to it
feelings you have much more control over
it's a lingering effect of an emotion
emotion in most at least most
neuroscience and and most studies of
physiology of emotion and emotion is
actually pretty quick to come up and go
right emotion can come in maybe 60
seconds 90 seconds sometimes two three
minutes in the extreme
but the emotion itself tends to pass and
now the brain is starting to label it
attached meaning to it decide what does
this mean what does this mean for me is
it safe is this bad a lot of mental
processing is actually taken over and
now it's creating a lasting feeling I
like the phrase take turns it means you
take a turn
many of You Are So Silent in what you
really think feel need expect deserve
want
many of you never speak up for yourself
many of you get bulldozed every single
conversation and you keep blaming them
for bulldozing
versus speaking up
many people do not participate in
conflict
they just listen
they get mad passive aggressive
they quit
they Stonewall
they refuse to set boundaries they
refuse to ideate
and they just get more and more
disconnected disengaged
stop participating and if you've ever
been in a situation like that with
someone else it drives you mad
it's just like I can't believe they're
stonewalling me I can't believe they're
not participating
and it gets very very upsetting for me
that's a big one for me when someone
like I know that triggers me when they
won't participate
in a respectful process I gotta breathe
I gotta move I gotta self-talk baby
emotional regulation because that one
will get me going
but I see it all the time
and so take turns means you take your
turn
and you set up the space that they're
gonna make theirs
you ask the questions to draw them out
you give them the platform to speak
you express what you need to express
you take a beat and you don't wait
listen this is so important if you want
to be a great communicator
after you've expressed what you needed
to express
please don't expect them
to comply
accept
validate or say yes to what you just
said
think about this way you just got to
take your turn
now they get to take their turn
then you get to move towards resolution
but what you just said was not the
resolution
what you just said was your piece
you took your turn
now they get to take their turn
in taking their turn their turn is not
set up they have to agree or comply
they just get their turn
and when they get their turn you listen
when they get their turn you reflect
that's the key
most people when you take your turn you
expect compliance
and that's where the whole thing falls
apart in conflict
that they have to do it your way all the
time immediately
oh man that sucks I know you've been
there before
but
the reality is most people think they've
been there before but don't realize they
put others there before too
and we have to take ownership of that
again this is not Brandon Richard being
perfect to you I've done this a million
times accidentally I mean I don't know
how many conversations I've had where I
feel like I've I've made a great
argument and they should just go yes
and then they don't I'm like how can you
not agree with that and then I argue
with them and it devolves from there
instead of builds from there because I
didn't make sure they took their turn
now that I have vented or I've expressed
now they get an equal part
to share back and when they share back
even if they didn't agree with me yet
and I'm I just want them to say yes I've
got to go okay Brandon
fine
feelings interests needs expectations
listen for those reflect goes back
because if they feel heard right now
then we can move to resolution
so key taking turns please do me a favor
make sure you take your turn our job and
our relationships is to create
real authentic
caring
interactions real authentic caring write
it down real authentic caring
real means that we are being who we
really are in that relationship
right we are being real with that person
we're speaking our real thoughts
feelings dreams desires needs
we understand and hear their real
thoughts feelings desires needs and
dreams we validate it we appreciate it
we are acknowledging it that's being
real with one another right we're
meeting each other as two people who are
separate we're coming together creating
a real connection based on actual
honesty and trust that comes from
sharing one another's real thoughts
feelings desires dreams needs
that's real
authentic
authentic means oh this relationship is
unique to us
so often we're taught in the modern
world authenticity is about us because
we all think of authenticity now as like
social media am I showing up real in my
social media but in real life in in
family Dynamics or sociology
authenticity is about the relationship
it's it's I am authentic with myself
in relationship with my sister we have
an authentic relationship and my
relationship with my mom is different we
have an authentic relationship an
authentic relationship with my mother
means different things than authentic
relationship with my sister as an
example right each person you have a
team you have a team if you treat each
person on the team exactly the same
because you're always authentic it
that's not an authentic relationship an
authentic relationship is that
relationship with them is real and
unique to them it's authentic with that
person
that's what we're talking about here
um we've got to be able to have on top
of this realness or this authenticity
this the sense of that there's a depth
or an intimacy in that relationship
depth would be like oh I know things
about this person
intimacy could mean the same thing which
means there's a depth there that can be
physical as well but I think depth or
Intimacy in sharing with one another is
really important I think most people
don't have fulfilling relationships
because they don't have deep
relationships they're always talking
about surface things they're talking
about what's on TV they're talking about
the weather they're talking about what's
in the media they're talking about
comparison to other people but they
never talk about the meaning of life
I would say you you barely know a person
until you've talked about the meaning of
life with someone
because what do you really know if
you're not connected or understanding
what their sense of purpose is or where
they draw fulfillment or meaning from so
this whole conversation we're having
today if you had conversations like this
with your family think about how deep
are those relationships would be I know
some of you are laughing right now
because you can imagine never having
this conversation with your family I
totally understand but I think it's
important that we say okay
if I want to have a great relationships
they've got to be real they've got to be
trusting they've got to be intimate
they've got to be deeper and the more I
would say this I was something with
Denise actually about this topic this
morning
and she was like when she thinks about
meeting and filming her first go-to is
relationships
first go-to
because you know if the people around
you
don't ever sense fulfillment
if the people around you
don't imbue moments with meaning
then now you're left to do all the hard
work and if you haven't done personal
development work before what ends up
happening is you kind of just take
what's given to you
and I think it's important that we
realize the people we surround ourselves
with should be people who understand
life's meaning who are seeking it out
people who want to feel fulfilled do
good things be Role Models because those
people Lift us up those people Recon has
anyone had an interaction with somebody
in the last year or two who reminded you
about the blessings or the importance of
Life make sure by the end of this year
you have wowed your relationships
wowing your relationships means today
you sit down
you identify the most important
relationships in your life
and you ask the question
how can I wow that person
this year
and it doesn't mean you have to do
anything extravagant and buy them big
gifts or take them on big trips though
you might have one or two people you
want to do that with
it just means usually here's what Wows
people
appreciation
a written card
some encouraging audio texts
a nice email
more frequent phone calls
it's simple
it's simple wow the most important
people in your life by the end of this
year now I know you might already have a
good track record maybe you had a great
summer with somebody carried on
see it through finish this year strong
in your relationships remember long-term
healthy relationships are a secret to
longevity and life satisfaction so who's
somebody that you could reach out to
with some appreciation some love some
encouragement I put this as part of my
morning routine some of you guys know is
I send five encouraging audio texts
every single morning
to the persons in my personal life
usually sometimes in my professional
life my peer Network or my team usually
for me it's my personal network of
friends and family who who've encouraged
me throughout the years and I want to be
that source for them
and so who could you wow
by the end of this year
maybe you've had a a tough year like
lots of couples did with your partner
your spouse
and you've kind of been struggling a
little bit and right now it's been all
about the blame and the negativity
and maybe you guys aren't even going to
make it
but could you still do something to wow
that person
I think that when we remember that we
signed up for the relationships we're in
our life
by and large
that you know okay I signed it up for
this I'm going to end this well or I'm
going to wow this person or I'm going to
take it as an obligation or
responsibility to make their life better
right it's it it's my job I feel in my
marriage to make our life better
to constantly surprise my wife to
constantly give and be generous into
that relationship even when it's busy
even when it's hard with little things
and I can't say I'm great at it but it's
always on my intention radar it's every
day I'm thoughtful about it every day I
try to do something and it doesn't take
much I mean the joy of my wife gets when
I pick up or clean up is amazing you
know so we all have different ways and
most people don't need you to do some
big extravagant thing it's the things
that they need it's you know their love
language it's their priority their
preference even if you don't like it you
know even if that's not the meal you
want to eat make them that meal that day
maybe maybe you've had a hard time and
you know you could hold it against them
maybe today you let it go
and you approach them with open arms and
open spirit
to try to repair accountability means
you know what my credit card bills those
are mine I'm accountable for handling
those instead of avoiding them I am
personally responsible to deal with
these even if I didn't cause all these
problems
I am now the person who if I'm going to
clear the problems off my plate I gotta
take some personal accountability for
that
I am now the person who gets to choose
my attitude today
I am now the person who expects myself
to follow a higher standard and to
follow through
accountability personal responsibility
or personal accountability says okay
I'm going to own this reality I'm going
to plan my way through it I'm going to
follow through
and I'm going to set up checks and
balances to make sure I do that
or that's setting goals and tracking and
measuring the goals and my own behavior
towards those goals
or getting a coach
sharing socially in the community or
talking with your friends and family and
putting it out there now your butt's on
the line and you got to do it
I think that's what's important
so often
we say you know
I have dreams I'm not going to tell
anybody
and often in person development you hear
people say no tell people because once
you verbalized it you can realize it
once you verbalized it and it's
socialized now there's an expectation
you follow through
here's my question too
do you have enough expectations
to follow through
often when I work with CEOs
as as their executive coach what ends up
happening is
they have that kind of
maybe they have investors and their
investors expect them to stay on path
maybe they need to hit their quarterly
goals
um but what ends up happening is
sometimes they start feeling like their
accountability
is driven by others
and often High performers
feel all these obligations they are
accountable but they're accountable to
obligations that other people have set
and if you want a real fast track to
being demotivated
stop setting your own plan
stop setting your own accountability
this is why for me as I told you I go in
my planned section of growth every day I
look at all those plans I'm like
I'm behind on this
but I don't get discouraged I just make
a plan on how to handle it
sometimes I look at him like I don't
like my score here with my friends I I
went three months without really talking
to my friends I don't get down on myself
I make a plan
I don't fall prey that victim part of
myself that says but all these other
things are happening and oh my God I
just go okay got it I don't like that
I'm the only one in charge of the ship
you're the only one in charge of those
scores
and once you realize that you're like
okay
I'm accountable what's my plan because
sometimes you've left your
accountability to your boss you left
your accountability to your manager you
left your accountability your spouse you
left your accountability to the kids you
left your accountability to somebody
else and you didn't internally own it
anymore if you ever been in my seminars
before I'll talk about this for a while
and then I'll get the whole audience up
we'll play this music we'll do the
lights and all of a sudden we'll have
everyone start shouting I own my dream I
own my dream I own my dream
to help them realize again
they're the owner of their life
you own your dream you own that impulse
in your heart that says to get better
once you are the CEO of your life
not just the follower
everything shifts for us
and that's accountability if you are
struggling with the sense of purpose
today
you are lacking a routine or a practice
to look at your tomorrows
raise your hand if you got that one
if you are struggling with purpose today
you're simply lacking a routine or
practice to look at your tomorrows
I tell everybody you want to be a better
leader you want to be a better parent
you want your day your health together
you want to build a bigger business you
want to earn more money you got to look
at your tomorrows way more consistently
not on January 1 or December 31st
but daily
that's why I forced myself to look at a
year calendar every day
because I'm not good at that and I know
that about myself and sometimes when
you're not good about something you need
to create a habit or routine that you
will stick to and find some joy in so
usually before I get to that wall that
Battle Board I got a cup of green tea in
my hand because I love it
I got a journal next to me because I
love that
I love green tea and I love journaling
I'm not so good at the vision part but
I've created the routine just like on
email I've created a routine there that
helps me go through a process that I
know I need to do but I'm not as good at
y'all follow
so this is what I'm suggesting to you if
you're lacking Vision we need a practice
to look at your future more often
so critical it's why when you do that
morning mindset prompt
in growth day one of the questions asks
what's a project I should keep in mind
that I'll be doing in the future
that I might not be able to do today but
I just need to keep it on the dashboard
of my mind
and people are asking well I when I do
this thing it's kind of the same thing
every day I I gotta you know I wrote
down I'm gonna write a book one day and
I got to write it again and again I'm
like yes you have to again and again and
again think about your future even if
you're not doing anything for today
you know even if you're not taking the
action say you have to think about
you know right now I'm thinking I'm
working on some major media projects I'm
not doing them yet
but I'm thinking about them I take a
moment to think about that project just
try to get in the unconscious
kind of scrolling around back then to
connect me to the Future
because when you feel connected to the
Future especially when it's something
that you are choosing to go do to go
build to go manifest
you will feel more purposeful if you
don't feel this day it's very likely
tomorrow you're gonna be like I don't
feel purpose
and you forgot that feeling the moments
of life that's presence
is part of purpose
and to feel them even more you bring an
intention to it
right to feel the day you have to have
the intention to feel the day right
intention precedes feeling
but most people don't know that they
have a feeling then set an intention
I don't like this feeling I'm going to
change
but when you become more conscious you
say oh I'm I'm going to enter this next
situation intentional it asks what is it
that I would love to experience or make
happen
in this next moment
oh I'm gonna go play with the kids or
I'm gonna go teach my kids math okay
I'm gonna teach my kids math let me not
just show up plop the book down look at
me go what are we doing but instead save
yourself okay
I'm about to go teach my kid Matt
I like to do that as a parent
how would I like to show up
what would I like that learning
experience to feel like between us
father and son mother and daughter
what would what do I want that to feel
like
even if they don't learn well today
what do I want the end
of our learning session to feel like
for them
what Association do I want them to
create
with learning math today
now notice that took me I think I
clocked it right just under 30 seconds
to ask those questions of myself
intentional living doesn't take that
much longer it's like a beat before
going into situation
you know let me
take a second here
to enter the situation more
intentionally
that is the process of bringing purpose
to a situation
right now I'm using and replacing the
word intention with purpose for a
specific reason because people get all
lost in Airy Fairy Land when they talk
about purpose but ultimately purpose
looks a lot like daily intention
and the more daily intention you have
research shows the more you say you have
a purposeful life
notice it doesn't say you earn more
built more did more it says the more
daily intention you have
the more you sense your life is
purposeful I recommend everyone get a
coach at some point because you need
someone to have that sounding board who
asks you next time
where you're at in your development
or in your progress or why are you
stunted or whether you're crushing it
and helps you tease out those lessons so
that you stay motivated and clear about
the next steps
and that's why I think it's so powerful
often the biggest shifts in our life
happen when we're accountable sometimes
it happens when you work with a coach or
some of you you become a coach I've
never been more accountable for my life
or had so many other people become so
accountable for their life when they
became a coach because once you're a
coach you're accountable to help someone
grow and you that instantly raises up
your awareness just like many of you
when you get a teenager and you start
talking to your teenager about health or
mindset and you realize you're a little
off it makes you more accountable
because as soon as you teach it you're
even more accountable to live up to it
remember that congruence thing
it's a beautiful thing the best I ever
became in my life is once I became a
coach because once I was a coach I was
like oh level up your identity Brandon
you got to follow through on these
things you have to be congruent on them
too you can't go out on the stage all
the time Tire like come on everybody
it's like I had to learn to take care of
my health that I could literally manage
a 38 foot you know stage with thousands
of people and and for multiple days it
was like running a marathon every single
day I I had to be accountable to that
audience because I was teaching it and
it was like oh as soon as you put
yourself in a roll of a leader a coach a
mentor a role model a caregiver as soon
as you're in that space you gain
positional accountability you realize oh
I better walk this talk because if I
don't walk this talk not only will they
notice I will start to dislike myself I
share that I I really share the the one
of the big Gates that happened for me
after my car accident it wasn't just the
car accident made me want to live love
and matter it was after the car accident
I had to sit with the reality that
I had built the life I didn't
intend to
I had
set in motion that relationship
that wasn't the right relationship
I chose the wrong person
despite some red flags
I allowed abusive language to happen in
a relationship
I allowed
um
I'd say resentment to carry on
I had done some things
and I'd experienced some things
that I didn't like and I could accept
them they did
but now I was accountable for building
that next relationship that had to be
better
[Music]
I had to make that next relationship
better it was on me I was the captain of
the ship
the director of the destiny
I was the director behind the movie Set
watching that character evolve I was
choosing
the next ACT
that's accountability that's a great
thing to have in life if you think about
the maybe the three biggest times of
your life that you changed
like those big what they often call in
Psychology is inflection points
or those critical incidences
what were the three times when just
major shift happened in your life
I promise there was a major gate to
awareness opened up for you either it
was an insight and aha maybe you're like
Eckhart Tolle you're just laying in bed
and all of a sudden you know awareness
and presence enters your life a new
level of Consciousness lands on
wonderful maybe you had to go through
something it was a divorce a business
ending you got fired somebody said no
you got in a Health Challenge an
accident happened
for me as you know an accident happened
I got in a car wreck and it was the
ultimate perspective check
at that point in my life
I thought I wanted to die
at that point in my life I'd been
suicidal and depressed
at that point in my life I didn't see
that my life could ever be abundant or
happy or loving
I I didn't get it
and then that car accident bam and that
was like a knock on the head literally
that opened up my eyes and made me
realize oh I don't want to die I want to
live
I just don't know how
and that was my awareness
it was
I I want to live I don't know how but
I've got the second chance
and I understand I want to live I
understand I want to love I understand I
want to matter but I don't know how and
that began a lifelong journey in
personal development and then psychology
and then philosophy and then
neuroscience and then high performance
studies to try and just understand how
do people change
well maybe as you're listening to you
what what were those three big things
for you maybe it was a health thing
something happened with your family
maybe you that was when you went off to
school or when you had the birth of your
first child or something happened and it
shifted you into another level of
awareness that said
I want to improve
I want to get better I want to be
healthier I want to be happier and if
you haven't had that yet then let me
knock on the door a little bit and say
hey this is a great time to gain some
greater self-awareness without greater
self-awareness we aren't resilient we
aren't authentically confident we aren't
vibrant we aren't healthy we aren't able
to deal with all of the chaos without
conforming to everybody else
the moment we lack self-awareness is
when the impulse to conform to everybody
else enters the moment we lack
self-awareness we don't know how to ask
for what we need in an argument with our
partner or spouse the moment we lack
self-awareness we make a bad decision
that we knew wasn't right for us
it's always the first thing awareness
some of the best celebrations you'll
ever have is if you just sit with
something for a minute
take it in
I was with a friend recently bought a
new house
and uh they had this great back porch
and they were showing me the new house
and we were walking around the house and
we're gonna do this and we're gonna do
they're talking about all the remodels
and stuff they were gonna do I'm gonna
do this and we're gonna do this and this
is gonna happen it's gonna happen this
time we went back to the back porch and
uh they were just kind of showing around
and they were Disney on it I said come
over here so what are you at I said come
here
and I had him sit down on the steps of
the back porch
I said
look at all this
I bet this was a dream of yours once
have a house like this
oh yeah it was tell me about that
and he shared about his journey of the
house he grew up in
which most of you and I would call a
shack
and he told the story of how he had you
know paid for himself the first member
his family to go to school
first member of his family to get like a
a a big job first member of his family
to give back to his Community First
member of his family to have a house
like that
and he was in that moment of just
sharing everything he's going to do and
I just made him sit down and integrate
it take it in and so I said literally
hey let's just sit here for a minute
just just take this in this is a big win
for you in your life you should
celebrate this just just take it in
and if you ever hung out with me you
know I do this a lot
I'm Gonna Make It Stop all the moments
we're just gonna take it in if we have a
big breakthrough together we're gonna
sit together we're gonna take it in if
we're you know if I'm out with my
friends or my family it's like we're
gonna take that moment we're gonna find
a moment just take it in
you got to integrate it take it in allow
yourself to feel otherwise you'll never
feel fulfilled I would be a person who
my natural tendency would like give me
all the potato chips give me all the
pizza give me all the bad food 24 7.
but the effect of it doesn't align with
my energetic vision and I know when I do
those things and I feel terrible the
next day it's so out of alignment for
what I want energetically in my life
my self-respect goes down I get down
and I'm less productive happy
does that make sense
very key to understand very key to
understand that's for me again I'm
sharing you my things another thing I
know feels good for me because people
always ask
I'm like massive amounts of water and
electrolytes every day like I really
believe most people are so dehydrated
they have no idea that most headaches as
an example are tied to dehydration most
people have no idea that their physical
stiffness and inflammation happens
because they're not have enough water go
through their body a lot of people are
so dehydrated and they're shocked when
you just like drink some more water and
like really and they start doing that
like this changed my life oh my God
another fancy little bottles all around
the house and they carry them along with
them you know
um I think it's important that most
people realize how critical hydration is
to their lives so I have to learn that
um I also know that what feels good to
me is a body that's not inflamed
by terrible diet or things that I drink
or consume that increases inflammation
as inflammation goes up fatigue goes up
as inflammation goes up weight goes up
as inflammation goes up life expectancy
goes down like you want to find one or
two main culprits of dis-ease in our
health physically inflammation a high
inflammation diet kills you sooner
so we have to figure out like okay we
have to study like what are the things
that inflame my body that's partially
knowing what you might be allergic to
right your food allergies as an example
but also just the basics of
understanding certain things that you
eat or consume tends to elevate your
level of inflammation and if you don't
know what those are see a dietitian a
nutritionist go read some books watch
some videos on YouTube about
anti-inflammation diets and you'll see
it completely changes your life did for
me part of purpose is sensing a mission
larger than yourself
most people confuse that with a large
achievement
but what it was meant to be
back in the day in these conversations
was it meant you can see beyond yourself
I can see the suffering of others and
want to be of service to them
I can see the suffering of others and
want to be of service to them where that
means your angry child or that means the
neighbor who's struggling or your friend
who just lost her husband
it means I can see beyond myself my
immediate selfish impulsive needs
and I can be with someone I can sit with
someone I can listen to somebody I can
empathize with somebody too often we
think of service as like
donation
you know did I donate to this cause and
by the way please donate to whatever
cause that you get behind
but there's different ways to ride
service outside just money
and the biggest part of humanity is
learning to sit with people
and be with them in their times of need
to let them know you see them
and you hear them
and you're curious about their story
and you want good for them in their
lives
not your way not imposing your values
not pushing the answer
but literally just honoring them as a
human being are social realm is
incredibly purposeful
most importantly is this and you all
know this as Strivers here in growth day
but I think this is so critical
you've got to be around purposeful
people
you got to be around purposeful people
if you feel like the people around you
aren't as purple as they should send
them to growthday.com you know it's like
maybe they need a little training a lot
of people need training
on this topic just like my friend I told
you about the woman I was coaching who
she'd never been trained to ask the
question what would make her feel
fulfilled most people never been trained
on purpose either
but getting around
striving
giving
generous kind compassionate High
performing people will completely make
you feel different about life
I think about my friendships and the
people in my life they got a lot of
purpose
and and it doesn't mean they have this
end game it means they're living
purposed lives with great intention and
appreciation and presence
so they're awesome to be around
do you have five people who are awesome
to be around in your life
like awesome
and purposeful
if not time to meet them when people
have clarity about their future
and clarity about their purpose it tends
to come in different categories here
okay so let me give you some of those
categories
first is yourself
I know that sounds like no doubt Brandon
but this is yourself in terms of your
identity
this is yourself in terms of who you are
becoming
and this is yourself
in terms of your self-worth
okay I'll cover those three elements
here in a second
self
in regards to your identity
who am I
self in terms of who you are becoming
who do I believe I am meant to become or
do I desire to become
and self in terms of self-worth
am I
Worthy
these questions
make you either feel connected as a
purposeful being or they make you feel
terrible
and so let's explore them
your identity I always ask this in my
seminars if you've never done this work
with me is from one of my other books
called the charge
and the charge being like the amp like
the battery pack like you know the the
subtitle was activating the 10 human
drives that make you feel alive look is
called the charge
and one of the things I started asking
people to do
in high performance work was to share
with me to generate and share with me
what are the three words
that would define
the best of Who You Are
today
like if you had to describe yourself
like let's say you went on speed dating
and you sat down uh across from someone
and the question was okay share the
three best parts of you
and with using one word describe that
now it's kind of like that right it's
like what's the three like if I had to
describe the best of who I am in three
words what would my three words be
what are your three words like what are
your three words that that is the best
of Who You Are
or if you struggle with that the three
words that would describe the best of
who you want to be
I want to make sure
that you have your three words and I
want your three words on a board or I
want the three words on your mirror or I
want the three words next to your
computer and every day you look at those
three words okay today I'm going to be
this
at midday am I being this
at the end of the day was I that
we need to develop a purposeful sense of
being and remind ourselves of it
personal growth and purpose is something
we cultivated on a very regular basis
otherwise you lose touch with it just
like most people say I lost my
motivation I go you didn't lose your
motivation you lost the practice of
paying attention to the things that
matter to you
and using your mind to rev you up for
those things
that's all
you started going through the motions
and so you lost the motivation
you can still do the same thing but
instead of just going through it
unconsciously bring conscious intention
by bringing purposeful being to a thing
it changes
well as you learn to make being a
purposeful being happen on a more
regular basis I promise you can shift
that's the hopeful message for today I
know sometimes you watch something like
this you're not in a good mood you don't
feel good there's been a travesty
something's going on in the world you
don't like and your day is just kind of
like all over the place
but that's why we're here
it's got to do it's like constantly
doing the work I would love for you to
all type this in either your journal or
the chat or the comments right now I
love constantly doing the work
actually write it down I love constantly
doing work you have to teach yourself I
love constantly doing the work
I get in an argument with my wife I'm
like oh I love constantly doing the work
like you have to keep generating the
ambition and the J engagement enjoyment
of doing the personal development work
you know I walk out of a conflict or an
argument with somebody and I have to go
recenter myself I'm like okay Brendan
chance to learn buddy
what do you got to learn
how can next time be better
how do I really want to show up
how can I repair this
how can we improve the situation next
time How Could I approach it differently
what can I watch for next time to make
it better
let me try
you got this next time Brennan
be graceful for today you got this next
time a little more intention okay here
we go
just over and over and over
giving yourself the grace to learn to to
enter the next situation more
intentionally
tough of purpose
time to go out and volunteer
my very favorite way to change someone's
life is to turn them into a volunteer I
don't care what they volunteer for but
go volunteer they will change everything
because who does volunteering purposeful
humans you know so it's my favorite way
to improve your social life if you're
not around purposeful people volunteer
you'll meet more professional people
more intentional people more present
people more appreciative people
but also if you are struggling in any of
your relationships please watch the
relationship trainings or courses in
growth day because they've found that
just one negative or hurtful
relationship in your life
can dramatically decrease your sense of
purpose in life
your overall sense of purpose by one
person and we know that to be true in
your career right you have one bad boss
they can ruin the whole company for you
well that's true in our personal lives
too
one negative hurtful person consistently
in your life tends to decrease your
sense of purpose in life
by three points out of ten
so meaning let's say on a scale of 10 0
to 10 you feel life is purposeful and
you're really connected to it ten you
feel totally purposeful totally
connected zero you have none
let's say you're as level seven
having one negative or hurtful person
recurring in your life takes that seven
down to a four
that's why
that's saying don't suffer fools
is a good one
if you got somebody who's negative or
hurtful it's time to do the relationship
work to either improve that situation
with that person
help them get assistance or helper
coaching or exit that situation
if you can't do any of those then you've
got to find a tribe or a community over
here that you build up that meets those
needs
and I think that's important because
sometimes people say well Brandon my
mother she's terrible and I hate having
around I'm like okay well you can't
necessarily replace your mama maybe you
can limit time there but sometimes
people can't they're they're caregiving
as an example
and like okay well then outside that
house we've got to develop the
relationships that provide you with that
sense
where it's lacking there in that
particular relationship
and so I think that's really really
important one time
um
I was uh about to kind of go pitch an
idea to somebody who I really admired
and right before I went in the meeting
my phone went off and I had set an alarm
in my phone this is before growth day
um I used to just set alarms in my phone
now I just use growth day for reminders
but I said and it went off
and one of my words at the time was bold
and the truth was I don't think I was
that bold but I was trying to become
more bold and I I know it was in me and
I know it's the best of me but it took a
lot of courage to summon like boldness
like take a big action or ask for a big
thing
it happened right this thing the
reminder went off right before I went in
this meeting
and the in the meeting people started
talking about this big new idea
and usually I would just kind of sit
there and you know listen and take notes
and I heard them and I heard the
enthusiasm and I loved what they were
talking about and I and I literally put
my hand on the table and it kind of made
a thump
and I said
hey y'all
I'd love to quarterback that what do you
think
that's all I said I'd love to
quarterback that what do you think
everybody kind of looked around the
table one person said you'd like to do
that I said I would they said go for it
and I got like a dream project
if I hadn't got that reminder to be bold
right before the meeting I don't think I
would ever done that and that became a
very critical in changing moment in my
life
for in terms of my career
and so I shared that with you because
there's a sense of purpose
that comes into our life when we are
being who we know we should be
at our best levels
but just like you need a fulfillment
habit
you need a reminder habit about yourself
because who gets down on yourself
sometime
sometimes the words you say about
yourself are terrible
and you're on repeat on terrible words I
want you to have positive words and I
want you to repeat about those it might
take some time I didn't even believe my
three words for the first year I did
this activity
but then I had the blessing one time of
uh sitting down with Oprah on her porch
in my in Maui and it was like I just
taught her and her team about change
management and we were doing this big
program together about your next bold
move
um and I had taught about these three
words
and so I asked Oprah's three words and
I'll keep that private to her what was
amazing is when she said them I heard
them I'm like yep yep and yep
they were all totally true descriptions
of who she was because she lived in
Integrity with that intention of who she
wanted to be
it was just like so obvious
and so the beauty there is as you
develop yourself
as you choose your three words as an
example you choose your identity and you
live into those words on a more
consistent basis you'll be more in touch
with your natural and best being I'm
consistently asking like what what's the
feeling I wanna
have here if you ever see me Teach it's
often I would say bring the joy
so I have joy triggers that I've set up
in my mind that makes me more
intentional about things so for example
a door frame trigger whenever I walk
through a door I say bring the joy
so when I walk through that door right
there it's like bring the joy into this
room
it's just it's just a mental trigger
that I've set up for myself every
morning in the shower I ask myself three
questions and not that I shower every
morning but the ones I do the first
question I say what can I be excited
about today
so it forces me to be clear about what's
going to draw Joy enthusiasm from me
number two I say what might trip me up
today
because usually I know what's going on
in the day I'm like what what might mess
me up what might where am I not perform
well what might bother me and number
three I say what can I do to surprise
somebody today to give a gift of
appreciation or acknowledgment today and
so I think through that in the morning
so I think that helps me begin my day
pretty clear then when I sit down before
I do work I literally look at my
calendar of the day this morning
and I look at whatever's going on the
day and I think about it for 20 minutes
it's one of my 20 minute routines in the
morning I literally
think about my calendar for 20 minutes a
day
and people think that's crazy but what
I'm thinking through when I'm looking to
count I'm like okay I'm gonna have that
call what do I want to have it on that
call
you know what's my intention for that
call what's my goal for that call what's
the feeling for that call how do I want
to end that call you know I'm gonna have
that time with Lewis like how do I want
to be there and and how can I make sure
I enjoy it because it's a big deal you
know I love your show I want to do a
good job I want to share something good
for the people even though I have no
idea what you're going to ask I want to
be present for that and and make sure I
I I'm I'm really there even though maybe
I have a head cold today you know it's
like that it's like just thinking
through it I think that helps me that
first thing we all want a greater sense
of is aliveness and I always come back
to this right reinvent your life for
what well could you reinvent your
mindset your habits your peer group your
work efforts so you have a greater sense
of aliveness aliveness is that sense of
a vibrancy of being of passion
of presence in spirit in the moment
we all want to feel that the good news
is we can usually get aliveness to
exactly what you know Jonathan Fields
talks about which is savoring the mode
more we can feel a greater aliveness
when we up our health
right get better physical health to have
more energy we can feel that
what else do we reinvent towards well we
always talk about another corner of the
the triangle of being about connection
specifically we want connection with
ourselves in connection with other
people
this usually is about the area of your
life called relationships right we want
to improve deepen our relationships
increase intimacy and vulnerability just
feel more real and connected with other
people
sometimes that changes your
communication approach with your partner
or your spouse
sometimes that changes your partner or
spouse I'm just teasing y'all I don't
know what you need to reinvent but it is
a major area of concern isn't it
another major part of that triangle is
Meaningful Pursuits
right a sense of fulfillment or meaning
in the act of progressing in our lives
or creating in lives or leading in lives
or building in our lives that we want
meaning and fulfillment but specifically
we want meaningful Pursuits because some
people have meaningful Pursuit they
actually have a lot of meaning in their
life
but they're not happy
meaning does not always equal happiness
it always throws people off they're like
I sprinted I have all the reasons in the
world to be happy I have a meaningful
life I don't know why I'm not happier
I'm like oh meaning and happier they're
different things
right what can add onto meaning
to make it more happy is aliveness and
connection but also Pursuit
right we we are human we love to chase
something we love to build something to
be in progress to be in motion doing
something meaningful
does bring us more happiness right you
can have happiness without everything
being perfectly meaningful right I can
eat a piece of chocolate with green tea
and I'm happy there ain't nothing
meaningful in it it's just a moment
right so you can have happiness
separated from meaning clearly but when
we are pursuing something that matters
to us and brings fulfillment that makes
a difference
and of course in the middle of that
triangle of aliveness connection and
meaningful Pursuits is growth
the sense that we are growing
now I've taught you this growth day
model many times so I won't belabor the
point but I do want to always re-aim us
at those things because after you know
15 years of coaching people one-on-one
in large groups there's no question to
me that after we have security and
safety in some level those are the
things we're always striving for more of
more aliveness more connection more
meaning and more growth what you find
meaningful and fulfilling tends to come
from things that you are doing
meaningful Pursuits that you find
intrinsically and deeply interesting or
passionate or even obsessive
in that you're like I just love this
thing so much
and the more that you love something the
more that you tend to find it to be
fulfilling
and so we've got to allow ourselves
to pursue our interests and our passions
to the place
of love
that when you have love in your life you
are more
in connection with what will make you
feel
fulfilled
and it will be in more connection of
what you will later on ascribe as a
meaningful life
never met a person in all my years of
researching personal development reading
all the great biographies being with
psychologists and sociologists and
psychiatrists and being with people in
Hospice at the end of their life
never met a single person to talk about
think about write about research or
experience a meaningful life absent
of love
not a single never done I've been read a
spiritual text that love wasn't the
center
of what humankind's meaning is
I've never read any research
that has found a happy person who didn't
have deep meaningful connected and
loving relationships
I've never met someone who attained you
know the remarkable status of a
billionaire or a multi-millionaire or
the CEO the most successful person or
expert in their field who didn't love
what they were doing
maybe they didn't love it every day and
that's a mistake that every day is
supposed to be perfect and joyous and
abundant and oh my gosh perfect no
there's lots of days that aren't but
they're on what I would call a loving
path
they're on a loving path they love what
they're doing they might not even know
what the career is but every time they
do that one thing
they feel a connection to it that's
different than other things there's more
interest more passion more depth more
excitement more something there
and we haven't been taught
to pursue those things
especially when we're young we're taught
to pursue avenues that lead to a
specific result that Society has said is
good you know we'll do this job because
it leads to that salary
instead of asking
what
what do you like doing what are you
interested in what draws your passion
what do you love actually spending your
time on integration what does that mean
um I always talk about this with so many
friends so many friends
who have had so many wins right
successes and they don't feel like a
success yet
so good things have happened to
themselves but they haven't integrated
that they are good
right it's that person who never feels
satisfied who always feels a lack who
never feels High self-worth why because
even though the good things are
happening even though they've made
things happen they've never put their
hand on their heart and integrated the
good things into their identity
so everything else just bounces off
that if we want meaning and fulfillment
to happen in our lives when meaningful
things happen we have to integrate them
into our life
we have to say ah that was meaningful
and you almost have to pull it right
into your body into your mind and your
heart you have to say ah
I felt that
you know
it's like I was recently at a wedding
and uh it was funny to see how different
people participate and see and
experience weddings to me it's just like
I'm taking so much of it in and I
wouldn't say because I'm an empath in
any way it's just because I go you know
what this is one this is one time one
day this gets to happen for them let me
enjoy this with them let me bring some
joy to this with them and let's make
this stay meaningful people know to do
that make this day meaningful make this
day meaningful on a wedding day or on
Christmas or on your birthdays and the
rest of the day
the rest of the days of the year just
blur on by
well I think that first you have to
choose to make it meaningful that's what
we do at weddings right but then you
also have to stop and feel it and
integrate it
I had a great mentor of mine um when she
found out I was getting married
she said Brandon here's what I want you
to do
at your wedding on your wedding day
after the ceremony
I want to make sure that you pull aside
your bride Denise
three different times and make a
meaningful moment with her
and really integrate it into your memory
and into your heart
is one of the it's the best piece of
advice I got ever about my wedding day
it was all right make a moment
feel it and really integrate take a
moment to pause and and take in life
your newborn is finally starting to walk
those are the moments where you take
that in and you just pull it in you
integrate that into your life as a
meaningful moment
but a lot of people don't take that same
idea when they have successes in life
good things happen and so even though
they have all the reasons the world to
be fulfilled they don't feel full
fulfilled because they've never stacked
or integrated all those good wins they
haven't taken a moment to think about
them and to feel them and to be grateful
for them you want to feel more meaning
and fulfillment in your life think about
life more
read some philosophy read some great
biographies of people who did great
things expand your vision
as soon as you expand your vision
there's a different sense of
I would say emotion and motion in life
expand that Vision again
open up that ambition again
now most people don't do that because
well you don't understand Brennan I got
disappointed
I failed they don't believe in me I'm
like and
if you let every disappointment or
failure or discourage are out there
pull at your life philosophy and where
you're going in the future if you forget
that you are destined for greatness by
God or you are destined for goodness by
a higher power or if you don't believe
in any of that if you forgot the
connection to your own future in which
you want abundance and joy and amazing
things for your family
well then we got pulled into the mud
didn't we today I get to share some
ideas with you on health that I've
learned in my own personal Journey but
also as a high performance coach
for 16 years you know one of the
fundamental most important things that
we all want in our life
is a sense of Vitality
and that Vitality is we want to feel you
know mentally engaged alert focused
enthusiastic we want to feel
energetically like physically
energized right physically we want to
feel a sense of that health and it's one
of really the only four things that we
all deeply desire we talk a lot about it
here in growth day that you can give
anybody anything but what we all really
truly want is aliveness that's what I
mean by vibrancy
connection with others and with
ourselves
meaningful Pursuits things that we're
doing that we enjoy or see as important
or contributing and growth like growing
as persons so all of that is really
important but that sense of aliveness I
always put that at the top of that
little diagram because it's so important
to us when we don't have a sense of
aliveness even if we have amazing
relationships
when we are fatigued and wiped out we
can have the greatest marriage or
partner or spouse or intimate
relationship but
the zest isn't there
we can have a great job we can have
incredible opportunities to serve we can
love our passions and our Hobbies but if
we're wiped out it doesn't feel as good
I know you all know this
and that is why it's so important that
we focus on our health
now I want to do full disclaimers with
you I am not a doctor I'm not a
psychiatrist I'm not a neuroscientist I
am not a health advisor coach or medical
professional in any capacity
I'm a high performance coach this means
I work with people primarily on their
mindset and their habits and their
relationships the first big gate of
personal development that I believe
everybody goes through in their own
journey to maturity happiness
fulfillment aliveness connection with
others ultimate life satisfaction that
first gate of awareness is I'm so the
first gate of personal change is
awareness
is awareness now I know some of you
already know this but think about this
in any given moment we can be aware of
our feelings
of our environment
of how our emotions are affecting our
minds of our decision making of our
surroundings of God of Universe of
connection to this very moment in any
given moment awareness can ebb and flow
can't it
and sometimes in your life I know some
of you feel this way you're going so
fast there's so much on your plate
you're so busy at home and at work
everything's going 90 miles an hour and
it's like it feels like you're so torn
from happiness or torn from the moment
that you don't feel connected
and that is when awareness is sort of
out the door and that's why in the last
decade the topic of mindfulness you know
went from sort of a a a a sort of a
subtle art to like a societal need
and as all of the research has been
showing in the mindfulness research of
how that can make us feel more grateful
how be appreciative loving connected and
kind and resilient it's become more and
more clear that people get this
but you don't go through the gates of
awareness all the time by choice
sometimes it it's pushed upon you
um I know many of you have had that
story just like I have in the past where
you weren't ready for change you might
have been resistant to change does
anyone have any family members team
members people in your life who are
resistance to change it's just like
you're around people like why won't my
husband change or why won't my child
want to be better or why won't my kid do
better in high school or whatever it's
like we all know somebody who just
doesn't ever shift into that and what
you need to know I'm going to make you
sort of a casual coach today or an
influencer or a leader today we'll use
all that under the term of influence
today if you you want to influence
others you have to understand they're
not going to start taking action to
change until they've gone through the
gate of awareness
and sometimes that gate of awareness you
can Inspire it you can role model it and
sometimes life just has to happen for
them we all know people like that it's
not a judgment sometimes you can't be
responsible for everybody else in their
lives you got to let life be their
educator please remember
anytime you have a frustration or a
conflict or an argument with another
person
please remember you are dealing with a
trauma Survivor
please remember
you are living with a trauma Survivor
please remember you are working with
trauma survivors
you yourself have survived traumas and
struggles
unfortunate incidents brutalities
difficulties awful situations in your
life
you survived him you're still here
you're still working through
you're still showing up you're still
working on yourself
if you can put the humanity in the other
person and realize they have also
struggled
and more importantly survived traumas
this will allow you to now be more
compassionate
empathetic
patient and understanding
because raise your hand if you think
sometimes you're in a conflict with your
spouse your partner or someone at work
and they might be acting out from old
triggers and traumas raise your hand
right you think you're fighting about
the vacuum cleaner
they're fighting about something that
happened in the fifth grade to them
raise your hand if you know what I'm
talking about
that the person you're dealing with in
that moment we always teach like
freshmen in college about conflict
you're not actually there in the moment
with that person
one of you is probably in high school
or in elementary school
you're in a situation or a moment in
your past that's being triggered to
bring up all these emotions and you're
acting out from the emotion
that's usually unconscious for most
people isn't that true
the more therapy work the more coaching
the more perspective more
self-improvement more healing you do the
more you're aware of those things coming
up and they will come up as we'll talk
about in my next point
but if it's true that something's come
up for you and it's uncontrollable or
It's upsetting
it's happening for the other person too
I had a great
um
uh interaction with the person at work
one time that I learned a lot
I was very much I know it's really hard
to understand but I was productivity
Brendan you know I was like man I was
getting stuff done it's hard to keep up
with me I am like I'm very I'm like I
schedule it I show up I deliver it I
schedule it I show up I deliver it and I
do it the positive mindset and I'm gonna
make it happen like that was really
really strong in who I was in my 20s
right and I remember
having this conversation and uh well
there's no better way to say it I was a
kind of a condescending jerk to somebody
at work
I just was not nice to this person at
work
um early 20s probably
just starting my career in Consulting
and a partner at the company saw the
interaction
and she pulled me aside
and she asked a question
that changed my life
she said Brendan
if you knew that person
was dying
how would you have handled that
situation
and I was like
whoa
I mean he was like I immediately I
literally went to tears immediately the
second she saw it she said that
immediately went to tears
it's like
whoa
now let me ask you that think about the
last argument or conflict you had
what if that person was sick
what if that person
was hurt what if that person was dying
trust me I know I know how the
pessimists and the people who don't like
personal development would receive this
conversation right now oh Brendan here
he goes you know I get it trust me
you're not the first persons I've
trained on this topic oh yeah sure
Brendan now I'm supposed to every time I
think about have an argument think about
that they're going to die sure is
practical
um
maybe it's not practical maybe it's
spiritual
and I say that because
there's not a single person you're
talking to who isn't dying
not a one you won't meet a person your
entire life who isn't dying
that's what we call in our work
mortality motivation
when we can see humans as mortal
when we can realize it's a short stint
for all of us on this planet
everything can shift a little bit you
have to learn to practice presence
practice presence being here fully in
the moment alive vibrant or at least
attentive right snapping your brain out
of that reactive like uh go with the
flow mode to no and being here
that oldest advice in all of personal
development about presence and awareness
about being with the flow about being in
the moment there's every spiritual
tradition has taught it as being Central
to human happiness and connection
this has been stolen from us because of
this
I really believe I I I'm stunned when I
hang out with people that they can't be
present for three minutes without
wanting to scroll through something I
mean they can't be I mean even four or
five minutes they can't do it anymore
because they have trained themselves
with millions of swipes
to be not present
and I believe that meaning and
fulfillment
um they become too fleeting
when we haven't learned to be really
present
and I think that's important learning to
be really fully present
and pulling that from ourselves there's
plenty of times I mean if you saw my
schedule you're like how do you get
present I'm like I've trained myself
otherwise I can just be pulled in the
next thing there's always a million
things going on around me and I have to
learn to just zoom right in and be here
with you
you have to teach yourself to do that
too
because the more days that Blur by the
less sense of meaning or fulfillment you
have you can be busy
but the days don't Blur by
right I'm incredibly busy I'm actually
this last two years I can't believe how
busy we got but during that time present
forcing myself each day to get present
so I can recognize and appreciate those
little moments so I can create the
connection with other people
so that I can sense that spiritual
aliveness of being here now versus
hoping one day to arrive to something
and that that practice of cultivating
presence of I would say and I know
people don't like when I use this phrase
but demanding presence I demand of
myself to be present I because I know
when I'm not I'm like Brendan get
present okay so I might bounce in place
take 10 deep breaths just to reset my
brain and my body
and that 10d maybe you do it right now
with me just stand up wherever you're at
bounce in place a little bit take 10
deep breaths
re-center yourself to the moment and
keep going
and that way you can observe life many
people they'll work their whole career
then they'll retire and they'll retire
and they'll finally be like oh wow look
at the color of the trees this is
amazing wow life looks pretty good and
they didn't even see it for five six
years they missed all of it even though
they were amidst all of it they just
missed it you have to teach yourself to
be with it to be here meaning and
fulfillment is so much as much as we can
Define it and have a destiny mindset we
can feel it
like I do it for like if I have a great
dinner with Denise like things go great
we just have a nice conversation I'll
walk away and I'll like be like putting
things away and just literally thinking
my mind
what a blessing
God I made it
thank you so much for this blessing to
be here with my wife what a great day
what an amazing moment we just had you
know what years later I'm going to
cherish that dinner
simple as that it's what we say to
ourselves
in the minute and after the minute that
really defines how we feel over the long
term isn't true
I mean the little moments if you can
celebrate them be there for them give
thanks for them I believe the more you
give thanks for the moments in your life
the more meaning you find
the more you give thanks for the moments
in your life the more you feel fulfilled
even if you feel years away even if the
next big thing is out there it's okay
right now you're feeling it that's what
presence is it's about feeling the day
more you hear me teach this now for what
20 years like you have to learn to feel
life
if we don't feel it then what's it about
and you're not just going to suddenly
one day feel it you know because you
drank a bunch of coffee maybe you are
but you're you're gonna you're gonna
imagine me on Kathy one day you're just
gonna you're gonna teach yourself to
feel the day and feel the moments more
you're going to observe more you're
going to breathe more
you'd have more intention and as you
learn to feel the day when someone says
hey you feel fulfilled about your life
you're like I do
because you are filling life
with presence when you fill life with
presence you feel full filled
it takes an active participation on your
point you're not just gonna show up one
day and feel fulfilled you have to fill
the day
with those senses of gratitude and
meaning and really
um I would say connection
if you don't do that I promise the days
just Blur by and the more they Blur by
the more you just stack on everybody
else's reactions needs desires drives
distractions their meaning and one day
you show up and you're just
you're really just a bag of everyone
else's intentions and needs and drives
and labels and meanings
and in that place
you're not autonomous
in that place
you don't get to experience that
individual sense of meaning and
fulfillment we've talked about from the
very beginning because you didn't take
the time to Define it consistently
enough when building a team what are the
strategies for influencing them to work
towards a common vision
number one if you were just establishing
the team remember people support what
they create so get their ideation
involved in that
but two make sure that team on a weekly
or monthly basis is revisiting that
vision
and talking about have them like
facilitated process work they talk about
how their contributions are what they
created serve that vision
serve that mission so that can be as
simple as hey share with me what you did
this last month but make sure you talk
about how does that help like in our
company our mission is to change lives
so it's like okay how did what you do
translate into changing lives talk about
that and just get people talking about
it way more often man like that's a big
piece about it is that most people are
doing like status updates but they're
not talking about how their work
directly touches the vision and if you
can get them seeing that and having that
conversation more often they'll
naturally start supporting it because
people support what they talk about a
lot right so you want to get them
talking about it I would also say that
you've got to have some kind of
measurement system in place whether it's
quarterly goals or weekly or monthly
rhythms whatever it is where they're
maintaining some type of momentum
right everyone loses touch of the vision
when there's not momentum in the company
when there's not momentum in their role
you can have the greatest heartfelt
caring awesome situation in terms of a
vision or a mission in the world
but if no one senses they're moving
towards it
there's nothing you can do to get them
to love it more
so you as a leader have to make sure
people are moving towards it and they're
getting recognized and appreciated for
it
otherwise I mean it could be you know a
mission of saving betas and they'll get
bored with a vision all of personal
development the goods part about it is
about the difficult decisions I really
believe that it's about the it's about
the difficult decisions and it's about
the disciplined habits that keep us
growing and extending and reaching new
levels of our potential that's why I
love it that's why I love personal
development that's why I love it so much
it doesn't matter how much I'm working
how tired I am where I've been in the
world how much travel how much work
doesn't matter what's going on with my
family my life my finance or whatever I
love
personal development because it commands
so much from you it says oh you want to
grow look at where you are young man
look at where you are young lady decide
is that the vision you have you're like
no then make the hard decisions practice
those discipline habits to go where you
want to go
I love that stuff
today's a good day to evaluate the
vision you have for your life
overlay that to how your life really is
and then make the difficult decisions to
start more
disciplined moving towards that Vision
that you want
enough of accountability
that lies within this principle so when
I talk about the vision decision it's
you own it
you're responsible for it you've got to
communicate it and you got to be real
about whether that vision is mapping to
today and if it's not you gotta initiate
the decisions or the discussions with
others to make the decisions what do you
find meaning in
is there something you love you could
give a few more hours to is there
someone you love you could give a few
more hours to
is there an interest or hobby a passion
that you just love doing and maybe you
know what it doesn't add up to the bank
account
I just get you on the cover of the
magazines
but it makes life worthwhile
you feel better you feel a greater sense
of fulfillment from life because you're
living life doing things and being a
person that you love
I think ultimately all meaning and
fulfillment all roads somehow lead back
to this topic of love
might not have all the answers on that
one that might be something for you to
journal about today
how does love connect to your sense
of meaning and fulfillment in life
that might mean you live with love
meaning you are loving-hearted towards
other people
it might mean how you treat other people
it might be the things that you do it
might be your life philosophy
however you define it I promise you my
friends love
that's the answer somewhere take care of
yourself you know do your meditation
your exercise get a good diet start
sleeping better start learning to sleep
better start taking care of yourself
better physically and I promise mentally
and spiritually you'll flower
that when you feel good physically I'm
telling you way more likely way more
likely to feel grateful for Life way
more likely to sense meaning and flow
and fulfillment of the day so get your
energy up because you know what when
you're wiped out
it's really easy to be pulled into
discouragement
when you're wiped out and someone says
something negative to you it's so easy
to believe them because you don't even
have the mental power for critical
thinking to talk yourself out of that
negative stuff they just threw at you
and you just you accept what they say
the emotions hit you just don't even
have the energy to mentally fight back
anymore
you got to take care of your health
first and foremost when I talk about
aliveness it always comes from a place
of physical vibrancy and health you've
got to take care of yourself and that
usually is for mental and physical
meditation exercise good diet great
sleep you start with those things
everything starts to shift everything
starts to shift and I say this all the
time because if you are fatigued all the
time you will be less likely to feel
fulfilled because you're empty
when you're physically empty all the
time how are you going to feel fulfilled
got it you got to fill your gas tank
once in a while take a break
do more resets throughout the day
Breathe Again
you know you want to feel fulfilled sit
and breathe and feel grateful for 10
minutes
simple you know we just got to breathe
again you know who feel incredible
meaning in their lives
people who cherish their life
cherish it
truly cherish their life
and if you feel like I'm speaking
philosophically to you I'm not I've had
the both the blessing and the very real
difficulties of being with a lot of
people at the end of the life and many
of you know I've volunteered in hospice
I've been with my own father as he
passed away
um
in our home
and I can share with you that
it's not until too late that many people
finally start cherishing
their life
really owning
and appreciating different parts of
their life
and if you can remember to do that
I think something magical happens
that's why I ask everybody go into your
growth day journal every day and capture
any meaningful moment capture any sense
of gratitude capture any event you
didn't like and spin that meaning into
such a way where you acknowledge what's
real but you're back in control of your
emotions feelings and your next actions
it's like by the more often that we
capture moments that we can cherish or
moments that we can learn the more life
becomes more meaningful but absent of
that self-reflection it's just a busy
blur
that's why journaling has proven over
and over and over in Psychology
including mental health practices and
yes therapy to dramatically shift
people's thoughts and feelings and life
satisfaction over the long term your
life matters my life matters those
people you hate out on the internet
their life matters
that what happens is we get so myopic
into our own world of okay is the little
thing I'm doing today does that matter
there's my you know the the this this
one thing I did does that make me feel
fulfilled and complete as a person and
we lack an overall life philosophy and
overall life philosophy
that we have defined our lives and the
context of humanity as meaningful
I know this might be too academic for
some people and that's why I use the
word or the phrase a destiny mindset if
you have lost that feeling
that says I have an opportunity to make
a difference while I am here You've Lost
That connection with what I'm calling a
destiny mindset
a destiny mindset and I know some people
will take a destiny mindset that's like
oh you know I got to see myself on a
cover of a magazine I'm like I had no
less people on covers of magazines who
don't feel a sense of meaning or
fulfillment in their life
it's not an external thing it's an
internal or intrinsic thing
that I just feel called I feel that my
life is leading to something important I
feel honored or privileged or grateful
that I can make a difference in the
future
and that make a difference in the future
thing
is a overall life philosophy that is
connected to Destiny
and I hope you start thinking about that
because you know what sometimes you wake
up in the freaking morning and you pull
this thing out don't you you pull out
your phone in the morning and what do
you do you start scrolling through
everybody else's stuff everybody else's
agenda everybody else's life and you get
trapped into the myopic looking at that
comment and getting sad or upset about
it you get trapped into small things of
Life the tasks the emails the responses
and all of a sudden you've been pulled
into this tiny little myopic to-do list
part of your life and you forgot the
being part of your life
you want to feel more meaning in your
life start your day with that Destiny
mindset can you show me somewhere
something that you look at every day
that opens up your mind and reminds you
to get out of that little myopic brain
that we all have that's just focused
right here
because if you never look at the bigger
vision of life
it's hard to ever feel a deep sense of
meaning or fulfillment if the only
challenges you're facing in life right
now are the ones that life threw at you
that's why you're unhappy
you're only in reacting mode you're not
in growing mode
let me say it again
you're in reacting mode not growing mode
you're going through the motions and
even if you're congruent you're being a
good person you're you're showing up
trying each day to be yourself be your
best
but if you still feel unfulfilled if you
still feel like you haven't broken
through that's a good Higher Calling to
honor that is saying to you challenge
yourself young man challenge yourself
young woman challenge yourself my friend
it is time to rise to the next level the
world the universe God your soul your
spirit is demanding more of you rise to
the next level
that is a beautiful impulse we must hear
and if we don't hear it it's because
we've drowned it with negative thinking
and the wrong intentions so we must now
challenge ourselves 2020 this year 2022
this year this is a year for you of
challenging yourself and not getting
discouraged see I can have a terrible
day and at the end of the day I can go
okay two years ago here's how I would
have dealt with that terrible day today
how can I improve how I deal with this
terrible day
it doesn't mean you don't have terrible
days anymore does it it doesn't mean
you're not tired it doesn't mean you
don't get stressed doesn't mean you
don't get frustrated
what it means is
you have the intention
to ask oh
how can I improve how I'm dealing with
this
how can I like what have you ever been
in a relationship where you and your
partner your spouse have the same fight
over and over and over and over and over
and over again it's literally the same
fight over and over and over and over
again no it's literally the same fight
over and over you ever had that
that what's lacking is somebody there is
lacking the accountability and the
consistent actions say how can I improve
this
how can I do it what's happened is it's
turned into a blame game right
this person's responsible not me
no accountability no action I don't have
to improve it you improve it you broke
it you cheated you're the bad one you're
the one bringing this up
and all of a sudden you you blame blame
blame no accountability I don't have to
change no action
if both couples get into that that's
where couples therapy has to happen
because they're both in the blame game
they've both taken the accountability
off they believe the lie that you know
relationships have to be 50 50 equal no
relationships actually mean 100 100.
you're 100 you're responsible for
yourself I'm 100 responsible myself and
it takes a hundred percent to keep
improving this thing and making a better
year over year
I think that's what people forget it's
not like huge dramatic shifts always
need to happen what has to happen for
most people to change awareness
acceptance and accountability
and then just small consistent actions
to improve
right it's like it can be that can be so
tactical and tangible I think of like
you know my career as a coach I
I just try to get better every session
it doesn't mean I'm always actually
better every session it's my intention
I'm gonna get better
every session with this client will get
better sometimes it feels like it goes
two steps back luckily it's three steps
forward
at some point and so I don't pretend
that every day is a bright shiny happy
place I just pretend that every day it's
possible to improve to improve my
reaction to improve my energy to improve
how I treat this person to improve how I
stay congruent
right it is that constant
desire
that constant intention to have
purposeful living and no one has
purposeful intention or purposeful
living and decides you know I don't want
to improve today
you can accept yourself and still want
to improve today
right the Dalai Lama can be fully
accepting
of himself
but he can also want to improve his
meditative practice right we all have
the impulse to grow improve develop
Mastery to remind yourself of how
capable you are because how far you've
come
the childhood you came out of
the trauma and difficulties and
challenges has been thrown in your life
and you're still here still working on
yourself
let's go growth day
you're still striving good for you
it's possible
it's okay to desire something great in
our lives it's absolutely okay so please
let that ambition back in as you think
about reinvention you can be centered
you can be happy and you can still in
that place of being centered and happy
build a great future in fact my argument
would be you can't do it any other way
until you actually open up a new realm
of appreciation and Consciousness right
here in this moment in your real daily
life
you're not going to build the greatest
future you can have
instead you're going to act out of fear
or lack or insecurity and you're going
to build another future that doesn't
have boundaries that isn't healthy that
isn't something that you want but when
you start from a place of being centered
and conscious and happy with what we
have feeling blessed you open up another
realm of brainstorming and a higher
vibration of ambition
that allows you to see a future in which
you are serving with Excellence caring
for others living a deeply meaningful
life
it all starts with allowing a mission in
saying to ourselves I'm worthy I am
capable and it is possible for me
if you believe that then I know you can
reinvent your life in whatever way is
appropriate meaningful and exciting for
you most people don't recognize what
they have until they've left it
or it's been taken away
then they come back or they want it back
and they go oh my gosh I love this thing
this thing is so valuable this is so
important this is so meaningful in my
life
and I always tell people
don't be that guy
be the person who sees it now and one of
the ways to see it now is to make sure
you're doing new
and then practicing self-awareness so
that you can have that little compare
and contrast and you recognize
the value of what you have around you
most people have so much more to be
grateful for than they actually are
because they don't even see it it's
right in front of them but until they
leave that context and they come back
then they go all right you know it's
kind of like when you were growing up
you thought you'd like you thought your
your parents your family everything was
just crazy and not awful and then you
went to another person's house that was
more crazy and awful and you came back
home you thought oh I'm so happy I'm
home you know it happens in
metaphorically in a lot of parts of our
lives right you thought your job was
terrible and then you took a new job and
it was way worse and you thought oh my
god what have I done right The Grass Is
Always Greener but the good news is when
we go through that open gate
and we walk back and forth because we're
trying new things throughout our lives
we can see that the grass is green over
here too and over there and we can start
sensing more meaning and fulfillment in
every area of Our Lives be open
be open
like what's going to attract something
new into our lives is when we have
created the white space around us that a
new energy could enter
right most people they say that they are
open you know well Brandon I'm open I'm
a liberal or Britain I'm open I'm a this
or I'm open I'm that no no that's not
what I mean what I mean by openness is
that if you think about it like
spatially right like this room what
makes this room open is the absence of
structure
does that make sense
so in your own life sometimes all that
structure that you're trying to build to
perfect things to organize things to
discipline things to keep everything
great that structure can also blind you
or prevent and block out more coming in
so sometimes you need to be okay that
your routine doesn't have to be perfect
that your habits don't have to be exact
that what your think needs to happen
when you go into that networking
experience doesn't need to happen the
dinner out with the girls doesn't have
to go a specific way that
you you in especially in social
situations you structure less lower your
expectation lower your anticipation and
instead go in with a full openness and
trust to that Universe a full openness
and Trust of faith that something
amazing could come in that you might not
have any control about if you need help
on this go watch that old movie
um
Serendipity with John Cusack and I can't
remember the the lady's name in that
movie but it was all about like she was
in this she's going to trust that things
are going to come back around and it's a
beautiful thing
so you have to trust that in your social
situations
that things will come into you
be open to that possibility of things
working out here's a simple way to do
that I call it the door frame tag
anytime I walk into a new door in a
social situation that matters to me
right I'm walking in to go meet somebody
new to go to a networking event to go
out with my friends into a bar when I
walk through a door frame I tag I
trigger my mind to say this
what's this going to be like
there's an enthusiasm what's this going
to be like not like I know what I want
like no what's this going to be like
people who are like what's this going to
be like have higher curiosity thus they
have higher openness and faith and trust
that something is gonna something cool
is gonna happen that's gonna draw people
into you like that anticipation that
something good around here is going to
happen that's going to draw people to
you okay so that openness that trust
that Faith whatever you want to call it
the second we have to do is to learn to
listen longer and I know you're probably
like oh yeah yeah yeah Brandon listen
like I know I gotta listen no I know but
people will say you know be a better
listener I say well the the essence of
being a better listener is to listen
longer
see respect is really just a
demonstration of listening a little
longer and I think what we have to do is
train on ourselves to be more patient
with people to listen to them without
trying to solve their issue without
trying to input Our Own Story without
trying to figure out the root cause of
what's going on for them I know this as
a man right when I listen to Somebody
especially a female and she's she's
upset about something or she's venting
about something or she's complaining
about something or is she just speaking
about something that she's very
frustrated with and it comes at me it's
easy I get I'm like I just want to solve
it I want to stop the noise you know but
that is not a way for me to deepen my
relationships what we have to do is
allow people to vent at us a little
longer without losing our patients
matter of fact some of my best friends
in the world I tell them the 20-minute
listening challenge when they get home
when their spouse comes up to them and
starts sharing about the day and wants
to talk about a bunch of things I tell
them just whether that storm for 20
minutes
just listen for 20 minutes try not to
solve anything
try to reflect back what they're saying
or just even be quiet and let them just
go and you know what the funniest thing
is after about 20 minutes almost
everybody runs out of gas
now you say no no no really my partner
can talk for hours and hours and hours
that might be true but usually when they
first connect with you when they first
see it when they haven't seen you they
just there's a 20 minutes of something
and at the end of 20 minutes they kind
of run out a little bit and they're like
oh yeah so so how are you
and that's when you say oh you know what
it was a really crazy day hey would you
mind if I just uh go get settled just
give them the 20 minutes just if you
when you pull up to your house if you
have to you know just sit in the car
center yourself then go inside the house
and let them get you for 20 minutes just
give them 20 minutes give them 20. you
can give them 20 minutes you love them
give them 20 minutes then get yourself
settled but if I think we can learn to
allow people more time to talk we start
to find greater connections with people
often we just cut them off often we
interrupt them we tell them what to do
and the worst thing we often do is we
say Hey you shouldn't feel that way and
here's why or hey why are you feeling
that way and we try to do some root
cause analysis when really we could just
allow them to express themselves and
they'll find their own way so listen
longer I think for those of you who are
really struggling to like meet
high quality people from your
perspective
I can't recommend enough that you get
involved with some local organizations
that are non-profit based and you start
attending more fundraisers more acts of
service and I know some of you guys I
don't I don't have anything I don't have
money to contribute maybe or I don't
have you know I don't know what I want
to do I'm like I don't care go to a
bunch of them and you'll learn what you
like
and I will also say this I know I've
been saying this for years I I beat a
dead drum a little bit here
but when you go to a fundraiser
or you go to a volunteer event do you
know who ghosts those
like you go to black tie event like a
fundraiser as an example do you know who
goes there
the most successful High achieving
positive wealthy influential people in
that particular community
people who have something to give and in
their spirit in their heart says I I
play this role in this community where
I'm going to make a difference here
I've met throughout the years I met
either doing the work of contribution or
literally on a non-profit board or at a
fundraiser because that striving
Community who wants to make a difference
I can't I can't share with that but
here's the thing whether you go do that
or you don't
the people who are closest to you if you
want to make a difference with them
if you want to deepen that relationship
find a way to make a difference together
go do something cool that contributes go
volunteer I think if you really want the
closest friendships imaginable you go
volunteer once a month or once a quarter
you just you don't wait for you schedule
it I want you to be the friend that
schedules the contribution
be that friend don't hope that person
comes into your life you're that
scheduler
you're that person who sets that up
you're the person that gets them
together because at some point they'll
take it over in all of my greatest
friendship circles I tend to be the
person who initiates it
and we do something and then sometimes
I'll do it next time like right
just do that acts of contribution
together just try
and what I mean by try is try with other
people again
I I watch people talk at lunch they're
not really trying to be engaged they're
not really there they just and it's
great that they're comfortable with
themselves but they've kind of they're
going through the motions and very few
things ever happen amazing when people
are two people are just going through
the motions because our default going
through the motions unless it's imbued
by like challenge or presence or
vibrancy usually our default is
homeostasis of just like yeah
and that is not very attractive okay
that is not something gets people's
attention when people get people's
attention is when you put an effort to
listen to them to be with them to be
present with them to change the energy
between the two of you for you to spark
something stop waiting for good energy
to come into your life and start
generating great energy and you'll feel
the difference try with your energy
again right really pay attention to
people be present with them they'll feel
that you're trying and they'll
appreciate it I'm not saying faking
right so if it's not authentic and real
don't do it but you must try more often
to show up as your best self into
conversations and to try and pull out
the best of others I think the most sexy
thing in a person ever is someone who's
trying to pull out the best energy from
you right whether they're trying to pull
out the flirtation of you or pull out
the joy of you or the Gratitude of you
or that positive range of emotions from
you that's pretty sexy so try to bring
out the best of others I do not expect
other people
to think or feel or experience life like
me
it just isn't there I don't think my
team members should think like me or are
like me I don't think that my spouse is
anything like me she has her own
Universe of emotions and feelings you're
very different to my trust me way
different I we think I think my family
my friends is like there's no
for me uh demand
that they
think like me doesn't mean I don't get
frustrated that we don't have a good
relationship or I don't like their
communication or I don't like something
they said or I feel neglected or hurt we
all have those things the question is
over a period of time
do you have depth and closeness in that
relationship
I promise there's a ton of things
Denise my spouse she would say that she
doesn't like about how I think or how I
experience the world
and I would say the same about her
but the question isn't do we like
everything that we say the question is
is there depth and closeness and
Intimacy in our relationship
and that only happens if enough times
you realize the person is different than
you
different preferences
different hopes different needs
like I'm I'm probably needier than my
wife is in terms of like emotional stuff
and just the way I am and you might be
different than your spouse your friend
your dad your mom someone who raised you
and if you're trying to cram the world
with this expectation that they had to
be think and behave exactly like you
that is where there is a ripping of that
relationship
you gotta let other people have their
own life
and the more you try to control their
life the more misery you have
a lot of mental health is letting other
people live their life
not trying to control everything
you know what mental illness is when you
feel like you must control everything
there's a part of Reinventing Your Life
that really says I'm worth it
I'm worth having a better future
a part of reinvention that says I'm
capable
no matter what I've been through I am
capable I am stronger than I think I
know I can build and architect the
future I desire
and there's a part of reinvention that
says it is possible
it's possible to change it's possible to
manifest your dreams it's possible to
improve every area of your life even
just small little tweaks it's possible
to have what you desire to be who you
know you can become to manifest a future
where you are happier and healthier and
wealthier and in more love with yourself
and your life it is possible I'm worthy
I'm capable it's possible you must begin
there if there's any hope for
Reinventing or changing our lives
because if you don't feel Worthy
well that's on you to change no one's
going to give you a permission card that
says finally hey babe
you're ready you're worthy you've
changed now
it is an internal reinvention of your
mindset of how you perceive yourself
and that perception of self
what that comes down to being is I'm
going to honor myself and honor the
gifts I've been given and honor this
breath and use the short time on this
planet to enjoy it and to build and
enjoy the life that I truly desire I'm
worthy of that no one has to give me a
permission card I have to open to my
brain and go you know what
dang I'm a good person
I went through a lot of in my life I've
struggled I've fought I'm here and I
still showed up today I'm worthy I
recognize at some point my attitude and
energy in the world was my choice and I
thought if I'm going to bring if I get
to choose over the long term
and in the moment
I want to experience Joy
I want to be happy and free and loving
and liked and I'm going to bring that
into each day
I really believe it and if you want one
thing from today if you could take one
thing as a major intention this year
I would ask for you to choose to bring
the joy every day it doesn't mean I have
to fake it till I make it it doesn't
mean that I don't have dark dark
difficult days and moments of my life it
just means on par over the average
across the days most often you're gonna
get joy from this kid that's a choice I
was not born that way you have to
challenge yourself to go to the next
level whatever that is for you right
whatever that is for you what is that
please write it down what is the next
level of challenge for you this year
in your business if you have a business
what's the challenges you're going to
take on
right whether you call that goals
priorities initiatives okrs you know key
performance indicators whatever you call
it those are deliberate challenges you
are setting a step ladder of ever
increasing challenges not because you're
gluttoned for punishment because in your
heart
you know
there's potential I think it's really
important to stay in your job in a
relationship and I don't mean by your
your employment right you can quit your
job but don't quit the relationship but
what's your job in a relationship it's
to love
and it's so easy to forget that because
we get mad at somebody and they didn't
run the task or empty the garbage or
take out the dishes wait I think I got
it backwards but they forgot something
and we get mad at them we forget our job
there is to love
and if you're really going to choose
love over choosing your past or going to
choose love over fear or hurt or pain or
choose love or being you know right
then you're gonna start to find
something switches in that relationship
and it's a good thing see most people
aren't choosing love they're choosing
fear most people aren't choosing love
they're choosing hurt and because of
that over and over and over again that
simple choice in the relationship
they're not approaching the relationship
with the intention of love right if you
can approach your relationship with the
intention of love to say look I'm just
going to keep bringing joy and love and
acceptance and compassion and empathy
and vibrancy and sensuality to this
relationship and you're always doing
that more often than you're bringing the
negative stuff that relationship will
suddenly start to turn positive it will
get easier as you change your intentions
to be more geared towards love that's
your job stay in your job in the
relationship to love this person to make
their day to surprise them to care for
them stop asking so much what you're
getting from the relationship and how
they've done you all wrong and start
asking what have you been doing right
what have you been doing to add value
love love energy vibrancy sensuality to
their life what have you been doing to
love them ask the question how can you
deliver more love to your partner and to
the world and you might start to
experience what we call the charge life
don't forget
to celebrate and integrate the winds
don't forget to celebrate and integrate
the wins
what should I do with my life well align
with those things that make you feel
alive deep in your relationships Chase
meaningful Pursuits and grow and don't
forget along the way to celebrate and to
integrate the wins now these are two
different things by the way lots of
people celebrate but they don't
integrate the win
I want to do both celebrate means hey
you had a good day great go for a walk
tell your spouse about it celebrate call
a friend celebrate celebration for the
human species is about social sharing
yes you can crack open that champagne by
yourself and and and celebrate but when
you share the win with somebody else
whole different level of impact in your
heart and your soul
that's celebrating share it with other
people small wins I put on my website
today
I got that promotion I said I was going
to complete that project I completed it
it's okay to celebrate and talk about
your wins we still live in a society
where we're supposed to be all Coy about
our wins and our achievements I'm like
why
uh by the way I'm not one of those
people I don't show you my jet in my
cars and my houses and I'm not that
person of like look at me celebration
but if we hang out we talk I'm like oh
my gosh I finished my book last night
oh you know I really want to donate to
this thing I got to do it I celebrate
the things that I'm doing that are
meaningful Pursuits that's important
but integrating the wins is something
separate integrating the winds means you
sit with the wind you meditate on it
and you acknowledge yourself you
acknowledge your efforts you acknowledge
the outcome and you cheer yourself on to
keep going
you integrate into your psych into your
identity
a person who is capable
a person who manifested something a
success
you speak to yourself in such a way that
you acknowledge your effort
you acknowledge the impact and you say
keep going
what it does is it builds a character
that knows it's capable
and so many of us
you've achieved a ton of things but
you've never given yourself any credit
for any of it so you're still
with a self-esteem of a teenager when
you should be a capable confident 45
year old woman
I know you're out of 45 year old women
apologize but you get the idea
some of you are still sharing your
insecurities as high school students
even though you have a job you have a
house you've made your house payment
you're doing good work in the world and
you're still lacking all self-esteem why
you were never taught and you never
learned to integrate the win integrating
the win can be as simple as at the end
of the day to sit down and journal on
the good things that happen
acknowledge that you worked hard for it
cheer yourself on as someone who's
capable and tell yourself to keep going
you're that simple you can celebrate
yourself just for being alive and
surviving this far the Habit is generate
energy okay not necessarily have energy
create energy create energy and what
they do the way we measure that was kind
of academic mental energy which is tied
to your focus and your stamina and your
ability to manage complex tasks without
too much mental stress number two is
emotional energy
which is just the quality or positive
motions
and number three is physical energy
High performers are 40 more likely to
work out five times per week
then
the rest of their peers so that means
the top 15 percent most high performing
people in the world tend to work out
five days per week and that workout
could be defined as you know 45 minute
brisk walk or you know hit intensity or
whatever it is but 40 percent more
likely that's a huge finding and what we
found is our performers just have better
well-being and happiness and physical
conditioning than everybody else one
stunning finding was uh CEOs senior
Executives and business owners
they report expending as much energy
as athletes who are competitive now I
can imagine yeah yeah I kind of I was
surprised by that I would have thought
you know athletes would be ten percent
more in the emotional and mental energy
they have to the decision making the
conversations the big deals the
stakeness yeah there's a lot of energy
it's a lot that's why I mean if you
really want to achieve your dreams you
have to care for your body yeah your
mind that's why all these things you
know finally resonating in the
marketplace because the science of
meditation or taking a break or you know
uh managing your own energy sleep is
everything
um and I think all of that is really
important and we say generate energy
because there's this myth that you know
some people have happiness or they have
it's like no you generated you don't
have happiness you generate it yeah you
create it what would be some of your
things that you've come up with that be
able to get that self of self-assessment
uh it happens every night and it happens
at the end of each week and it happens
at the end of each month okay so every
night uh and I codified this into the
high performance planner eventually some
of my perspective but we also did the
research of the world's highest
performing people sure because you have
a book that's all focused on all the
high performance research and everything
yeah it's called high performance habits
it's the biggest study that's ever been
done on high performers worldwide and I
learned a lot about like how they speak
to themselves and what they ask
themselves and how they evaluate and so
it was very clear that at the end of
each day they do it sometimes it's
unconscious sometimes it's very
deliberate and written out but sure
they're essentially asking okay this day
what was great about it this day where
did I not do as well this day what did I
learn about somebody else would I learn
about myself what did I learn about my
team what did I learn about my business
sure they're they're connecting with
what they learned that day right and
that's a real big part about it okay
um they're asking uh you know how could
I have handled this little thing better
and they're asking like did I enjoy it
right was I fully here was I alive was I
present with whatever it is in some ways
they're asking those types of questions
um in the high performance line I also
put here's the six major habits we found
from research matter the most and you
score yourself on them so I score myself
then at the end of the week
I so you're doing that on a daily basis
I do that on the daily then every Sunday
I do my weekly review on Sundays and I
look back to the week and I ask very
similar questions about the week but at
the end of on every Sunday I look at the
10 major areas of my life
10 major areas of our life are things
like Mind Body Mission okay family
friends uh Adventure finances uh you
know these types of things right so look
at 10 and everyone should have their
measurement you know their blocks of
things that they look at every week and
then I Square myself on a score of one
to ten okay so maybe that week my
friends you know what I didn't see
anybody I'm I'm a three I'm a good
friend I really wasn't I didn't do it
I'm a three out of ten right but you
know maybe my mission I crushed it that
week I'm a nine
and so I if you score yourself every
week right you will get better it
doesn't mean it won't be sometimes
disheartening discouraging or you know
frustrating sure
but being aware is half the game but
most people don't schedule awareness
every morning you got to get up you got
to pick up that Spear of purpose you
gotta cast as far as you can see it
today
throw that cat that's that Spirit of
purpose as far as you can today
as far as you can and then your day
is to go March towards that spear with
so much commitment
so much discipline so much resilience
that then you get that spear you get to
throw it out as far as you can again
that is having the vision and that is
having the discipline to go get it
the interesting thing is you have to
take that outside of your head
you probably have a clearer vision for
what's important to you
than your wife does
then your partner does
then your friends do
then your family does
and so a huge part of the vision
principle is you've got to communicate
it more
you got you you got to help everybody
see what that Vision ends up being where
they participated or they didn't
depending on your timing and now it's
like oh this is the thing we're rallying
around this is the spear I'm gonna throw
it we're gonna go together okay great
let's go and that command of the vision
is what I mean by the vision decision it
doesn't mean other people didn't
participate it but you own it you own it
the big part about it is your life's
decisions
whether you are conscious or unconscious
throughout your life
your life's decisions were leading to a
vision
and today is a good opportunity to say
is this the vision
is this what I wanted
or did I not know what I wanted
did I just go along the ride with
everybody else and do what everyone else
told me my whole life or
did I architect this was I
thoughtful about what the decision was
what I was after
today's a good day
to look at the vision you have for your
life
and ask does it match
what your reality is today to learn to
role model positivity and good values
right it's super hard to attack me
online at this point because for a
decade and over 300 episodes of a
podcast and over 200 episodes of my
YouTube videos and you know six
best-selling books and and literally
being on stage in front of millions of
people and graduating millions of people
from our online courses the just the
effort of all that the messaging is so
clear right I'm the guy that tells you
to be more intentional I'm the guy that
tells you to be a role model I'm the guy
that tells you be excellent at what you
do so you can be of Greater service to
the world and the more I talk about
living fully and loving opening and
making more of a difference of stepping
into that role model mindset of honoring
the struggles of life
in being authentically you the message
ends up standing for itself
you know they could attack you in a
video remember I like my shirt in this
video and I think it's stupid I took a
picture of you know the cat or you know
they don't they judge me or my clothes
or my wife or something they see but the
totality of what you have done
and no one gets to take away from that
they just don't even if they attack it
because here's what happens remember as
you build that big tribe you've imbued
good values in the marketplace your
tribe starts fighting for you your tribe
starts canceling the haters your tribe
starts fighting back for you explaining
for you your tribe starts getting your
back because they're like wait why are
you judging this guy he's put out a
decade of free content why are you
judging this person they've done all of
these good works and your community your
tribe ends up getting your back when you
have imbued that tribe with good values
and honestly demonstrated but also
commanded demanded bagged pleaded
cajoled for people to be positive forces
in the world you know at base of all of
my messaging has always been that did I
matter message
that message about servant leadership
the message about get so good at what
you do so you can be of Greater service
to the world like how do the haters come
at me when my message is about
contribution
that's what you want to think about is
that as you role model positivity
contribution good values in the world
your tribe stands up for you but you
also stand up for yourself more because
you know true down deep in your heart
you're doing good work but no one can
make me question my work I'm going to do
this I tell my team all done I'm gonna
do this till I'm 100 years old I'm
always going to be that guy putting out
personal development and psychology work
I love that field it's what I care
deeply about and it's what I've stood
for for a decade and no one gets to take
that away from me no one gets to take it
away from you so please don't let a
hater ever slow you down I hope that
supports you and I hope you always
believe in your message you have a voice
you have great art and contributions to
give the world do not slow down when's
the last time you tried to make the
person you're talking with feel like the
only person in the world you know we do
that when we're dating you know we're
out on a new date with somebody man we
just want to shine with all that
attention but over a period of time it's
like honey give me a beer or you know
people just stop paying attention they
don't even see the people they're
talking with they never look in the eye
and actually connect anymore they don't
try to make that person unique and
amazing and so what happens
the person's the the vibe between the
two people is lost
so have you been doing a good job in
that department making the person in
front of you the only person in the
world you want to have a better
relationship with your kids or your
spouse or your team or the new people
you meet at networking functions I mean
it doesn't matter when you meet a person
if you just shine your full attention on
them they're gonna be like that person
has such good energy I don't even know
why it's because you're giving them
attention so people have to have that
balance of those recharge and Recovery
moments right and those moments of like
being in the game sure and so much of
what people don't realize is you're
always in the game everything you're
doing now is preceding that next thought
right everything you're doing you know
four hours ago is and what you put in
your body four hours ago is preceded the
energy you feel now and I tell people
you don't realize you're always a little
bit in training you're always sure
you're always setting yourself up for
success or failure and it doesn't mean
you have to be like on all the time it
just means be deliberate and thoughtful
about your habits and what you're doing
throughout the day so that you can
quickly call forth your Genius that you
can quickly and easily flow into the
things with your most exceptional side
that you can be intentional and
thoughtful and kind with other people
because you are in touch with your full
Humanity because what most people are
doing is they're so disconnected from
their body so disconnected from them
because they're just going and they're
running they don't realize it but it
shows up in their life they're running
in an avoidant strategy in their life
right and avoid because of avoidance
yeah feels amazing avoidance is a great
short-term strategy sure to guarantee
comfort and safety wow and avoidance is
also a great long-term strategy to
guarantee suffering
right so avoidance now feels good
avoidance later will wreck your life
sure if you keep avoiding life and what
most people are doing is they're
avoiding their absolute best they're
avoiding it because the absolute best
requires them to put it out there a
little bit more right the absolute best
requires them to like use their brain
hard with their physical body harder
schedule
there is no discipline without a
schedule
it's so easy if your calendar doesn't
have anything in it the next six weeks
don't be mad at yourself for lacking
discipline no one shows up on ego it's
discipline day and has nothing to do
discipline requires the schedule so fill
out your schedule work the schedule
fill out the schedule work the schedule
fill out the schedule works as you fill
out your schedule and you work the
schedule
you get more self-trust with that
self-trust comes Confidence from that
confidence comes more confidence we gain
more Mastery and we're in the game more
we feel good about ourselves the
progress mind loves it eats it up hey
we're doing it we said we were gonna do
it we did it we moved towards our
outcome today with the schedule what an
idea right I've got ideas how to make my
team more High performing but some of
these ideas involve organizational
changes that would require buy-in from
my managers and peers what can I do to
persuade others in a culture where
change is often resisted and slow
um you know what changes almost always
resisted and it's always slow so the
most important thing you can do Jeff is
to realize the simple phrase I teach it
in everything I do I might have been in
the video and that the most five
powerful words in all of leadership is
people support
what they create
if you want buy-in from people you have
to facilitate a process
where they came up with the answers
if you want buy-in from people you have
to facilitate the discussions and the
meetings
and the decision-making process in which
people put their ideas into that hat
because then when it's their idea they
support it when they had no input to the
words the idea they always fight it if
they got to contribute one little piece
of them even if they don't want to do it
and I've had conversations with team
members at one of our companies before
it's like listen I know you don't like
the idea and you're not even sure of the
general direction
but I want to make sure you've got at
least a piece of it so what's one thing
you could contribute or give to make
this more successful what's one area you
could play in what we're going to do
that you might like
and just get them I mean get their foot
in the door of doing something or
contributing something or agreeing to
something because when people have skin
in the game which is their ideas or they
can see their future towards it when
they have that kind of skin in the game
they get excited about it and they
support it the worst thing you can do is
go roll out something to everybody that
changes everything without having had
them participate
right participation gets buy-in
got it participation gets the buy-in the
strongest relationships are built on
encouragement
right we know this from the social
sciences
um I know many of you guys heard me
recommend you know for the last decade
the work by John gottman and and his
wife in research and relationships I
love that work and one of the critical
things that came out of that was such a
simple distinction that happy couples
tend to praise each other five times
more than they complain or negate
and whether that ratio is true in all
relationships across all cultures uh is
not is probably not super validated but
what I do believe
is the simple way to break that down is
encourage your partner a lot
a lot encourage them cheer them you know
they got a big day do something look at
here I got this
on this uh laptop over here from Denise
can I see that you guys probably can't
see us too
no I'm not gonna show it's just it's a
poster note that she gave me like six
months ago I still have it on my
computer it says I love you I appreciate
you I know you are doing big things
I love you I appreciate you I know you
are doing things it was just a Post-It
note she put on my computer in a really
particularly difficult week that I was
having
and
we're both pretty good about leaving
little notes around for each other
especially when we're traveling or we'll
be a part or something like that but
also throughout the day like she put
something over there that she likes or
she does I'm like I love that good job
that's amazing and we don't say that
flippantly like we were like that's
that's great that's amazing like we
cheer each other on a lot and I think
that's huge the ability to encourage one
another is so vital so vital people with
good mojo they have more joy and
enthusiasm for what's coming up and for
what they're experiencing so in this
present moment they're taking it in more
with a great level of appreciation and
gratitude and because they're doing that
they're kind of playing with the moment
right now there's joy it's kind of like
they're that person who's opening that
gift at Christmas
you know they don't they don't even know
what's in it could be a small gift a big
gift but they're like they're excited
you can see there's enthusiasm for
unwrapping this gift well they bring
that same joy and that same enthusiasm
to unwrapping this experience that we're
gonna have together for unwrapping this
moment for even if they're just at the
restaurant waiting for the meal they're
excited for the meal to come there's a
an amazing Mojo around them because
there's enthusiasm you know they're
breathing life into the moment they're
they're feeling
um a sense of excitement for what's
about to come next so they're so fun to
hang out with because it always feels
like something's about something's about
to happen because you can just sense
that energy from them that they're
excited and appreciative of the moment
how do you ensure that a new team member
is quickly integrated into the high
performing team Andrea two things number
one you make sure you understand where
that new team member is going to play
and you assign a lead in your company to
Mentor that person
you make sure first and foremost if it's
your team you sit them down you talk
through some of the things that I've
covered so far already about what is it
that we do here what are we trying to
create here that you make sure that that
person is really clear about kind of
like what they're going to be doing on a
weekly or monthly or quarterly Rhythm
like a rhythm is everything which we'll
talk about and that's they have somebody
who's kind of their peer or their guide
or their lead over their first 60 to 90
days at the company it's huge huge huge
especially if they're not starting with
a group I tend to like to hire in groups
and I highly highly recommend that if
you're going to hire another five people
don't hire one in September one in
October one over November be like okay I
guess if that means hiring people
earlier you hire them earlier a little
later a little later but if you can hire
in groups then you create culture
if you're always hiring one-offs it's
harder to do that so first hiring groups
if you can't hire in group hire that
lead make sure that they are very clear
on their Rhythm and that will help
Andrea sold that to assist you with how
to think through
that process because you made it this
far in a video I want to celebrate you
most people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for some incredible John Assaraf
motivation check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there what's the number one reason we
procrastinate is it because we want to
have you ever heard of the law of
secondary gain so think about this for
just a minute when you procrastinate